all
right we're live we're live now my youtube dokeybird yeah is
yeah yeah i think that's how youtube i don't know you look
up dokeybird that's where i am not a kid's channel not a
kid's channel not i just hope i don't get flagged kids
channel wait wait wait okay don't change my game to roblox
this is not a kids channel children leave you're not welcome
here you there you i my my roblox account got banned wait
your roblox account got what did you do my my main roblox
account i tried to log in to to add you and it told me that
my main roblox account got banned for a bad username when
when was the last time Roblox I don't even know it told me
March 20th so like a week ago they banned me I don't have
even been on for like a week ago I don't know how they
fucking like sniffed me out but they told me I couldn't I
couldn't have the name ass you could okay to be fair how did
you get away with you can't even say like you can't even say
like woman in Roblox you can't say women wait okay can you
say women with an E or woman with an A?
Not either?
I say either.
You can't say women don't exist.
You're right.
Women don't even exist in video games.
They're so true.
So true, Robo.
Guys should know that women aren't real in video games.
Women literally aren't even in video games.
They're not real.
Women aren't real.
I got the sensor block.
behind every vtuber is a man with a voice changer they were
right they were always right they were always right
everybody who appears at cons yeah those are hired hired
women who pretend to know who pretend to know about video
games and vtubers yeah you want to catch one and just walk
up to them and be like okay so you're a girl huh you're paid
after video games reading video yeah you like your character
yeah what what's your favorite pokemon game in the pokemon
series name three star days from pokemon diamond and para
what what in your opinion what was the most based pokemon
protagonist um in your opinion would you smash your pass a
guard of war only women cannot answer this question.
Women can really discern the popularity difference between a
low punny and a guard of one.
What is the, what is, which Pokemon has the egg type to,
Pokemon is sexually compatible based on egg type.
And if they can't even answer that, they're not real women.
Your maternal instincts should give you the answer already.
What?
So true, only a real, real man behind me too freaking.
God, we've just started 10 minutes.
We've gone so far.
Oh, oh, oh, Toggy, did you, did you learn to do the, the,
the collab thing where you're like both on the screen
together?
I don't know, have you done that one?
I've done that before.
Yeah.
I always like to do that, but I don't know.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We could do that.
You can set it up cause I'm lazy.
okay i think i just need to add you on steam if that's oh
yeah yeah yeah let me grab my code it's okay guys we're your
digits now you guys can listen to us set up this so much
more professional you got you got roblox installed already
right yeah yeah i got the wait we had to install rob what
okay well it's like it's like a browse it's like a launcher
so basically when you click play it's just it'll like boot
up a window it's not really like a program but you do kind
of have to do like a little bit of a download okay yeah
that's fine i have fiber we should be good i have five she
got those optic cables yeah i was like i was like you have
to doubt i thought it was a browser game what i think i
think it used to be but they have they definitely have their
own little like program now okay let me i'm i think like the
saddest thing i've ever heard about roblox was when they got
rid of the oof sound because it got copyrighted I thought
that that happened.
That's so sad.
I just feel like you just opened the room.
That's when Roblox went downhill.
I live in the constant realization that all games these days
just mimic Roblox.
Like all these games, I'm like, this is just Roblox.
Like Fortnite.
Really?
Like what?
Like, you know that new one that's come out?
Like content warning or like- Oh yeah, content warning.
I wanted to try it out.
I haven't played it yet.
Oh, we should play it sometimes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, me too.
I really want to...
My friend linked me to...
Like, one of my friends linked me to one of the content
warning videos where...
Where...
Oh, no, they deleted the link!
Oh, no, they didn't!
Where it was like...
They were...
It was...
How do I explain it?
Actually, it's nothing you explained.
I'm going to link it to you.
What does this look like to you?
And...
What is this?
Can you explain?
He's not anything about it.
Dear Lord explain he explained to the class what I sent you
Holy matrimony
This is what I'm about to do to you guys is why oh my god
Whoa, I disappeared because I my steam was like we have to
restart your steam.
Goodbye everybody
I'm gone from the screen.
All right guys look thank god i am playing a game that's
totally not for children because what i'm gonna link in chat
is not appropriate
just so you guys know what i'm about to link to the chat is
hella inappropriate simply how the children are made so so i
hope i hope there actually is no kids because i'd get in
especially when i'm playing roblox anyway this is what i
sent snuffy
enjoying i'm gonna be using this one for a while whoa yes
aren't you guys excited for content warning the game i don't
know anything about it so this is just even more like how do
you get apparently it's like it's like lethal company but
like what if you're doing it all for content it's it's what
it was yeah it was made to be a streaming game it's
literally lethal come company but like you film it's like
let's do it for the vine you know that type of shit yeah do
it for the vine yeah do it for the vine the video game
exactly jump and be like yeah and you can die apparently you
can die too because you know
all right what do i how do i join you oh yeah did you add me
yeah yeah yeah i added you okay uh am i not popping up on
the screen oh there i am okay welcome to v so okay so uh
blah blah blah do you use you use a spout capture uh i used
what sorry when you do ovs streaming uh with vtube studio do
you use spout capture or do you just use like a game capture
game capture yeah i was like okay okay uh maybe hide your
model so you don't like show any information then okay okay
if you click your little side button items in the background
does that appear on your stream and stuff the little yeah
yeah yeah yeah i hit it guys i'm gonna be gone for a little
bit give me a sec you should check that out spout capture is
fucking amazing like literally it hides all the UI for VTube
Studio and it runs way better.
I 100% recommend it.
Okay, I'm going to write that.
I'm going to re-watch this bot because I'm not going to
write this down.
Time stampers!
I got a set of password.
Time stampers, if you're going to post my timestamps in my
YouTube comments, remember to write this one down and put it
in all caps and bold it if you can.
Just so I can remember to watch this part.
Okay, so it should be wait, what did I make the password?
So I'm going to like, I'm going to invite you to something
and then you just have to put in the password and I think
that's nice.
Password is empty.
Also, like, one of my one of my dragoons was like, my
favorite description of content warning is is basically
lethal company, but you are Jake Paul.
Oh, gosh.
I heard he's like boxing some.
Wait.
forgot the other one i can't remember which one okay sorry
like yeah yeah even you're like wait was there two of them
how many how many paul's are there was it jane john i'm just
naming like the beetles at this point
okay to be fair they all like they both blur together for me
because they both like doing the same thing now what except
for one owning one owns an energy drink and is like spawn
like is sponsoring a fucking basketball team now whatever
yeah yeah prime i got prime have you ever tried it no have
you ever tried any of the like content creator like did you
ever try the pink whatever or the pink juice or something
pink was that pink oh the pink sauce that was a content
creator that was just some oh some some fucking like a
famous person no it was just some tick tocker who tried to
mail like sauce.
Like, like, you never heard of it?
Like, like, okay, it was just some TikToker who got viral
because she made, like, you know, pink sauce.
And then she was like mailing like the sauce in like just a
fucking envelope to people.
Like, there was no cooling or anything.
She just mailed a fucking bottle of sauce to random people.
So like the sauce was like dripping out or exploding.
And it was like I seen it I seen it at like target.
Yeah.
Yeah And then like some fucking sauce company bought bought
the brand.
Yeah.
They're like John sauce I need this on my shelf.
Wait a minute.
We the pink sauce that's that's what we need the boo says it
just needed to be pink next They're gonna make the sauce
blue so they can make his and her sauce.
So and then and then the her sauce is like yeah yeah and
then the her sauce is like five dollars more expensive even
because it's pink i'm at the pink tax like the gender reveal
like barbecue party what gender is your kid grab your his
and her sauce today i got to have my wedding and please make
sure that the his and her sauce is there i need to be sure
that the women use the pink sauce and the men use the
ketchup anymore sauce i use the shrek ketchup she uses the
purple ketchup i don't remember what it was purple ketchup
but i forget like what we're quirky we don't we don't we're
quirky we use the shrek and the shrek and purple sauce the
purple there was a purple ketchup right ketchup i know about
the green ketchup it was the easy squirt hind's easy squirt
oh wait i'm gonna send you the picture of it i feel like
it'll hit you like a rock like what what an amazing name oh
that looks disgusting that actually looks disgusting they
make green and purple but not pink and blue it's literally
right there those are like the more like muddied colors of
just like chaos like what oh so guys i'm disappear again
because uh snuffy sent me the thingy uh but like what who
thought green and purple was like the colors to do when pink
and blue was right there like why do you think pink and blue
is more appetizing like what is the tastiest color and green
is okay and green is much better you don't want to have
green sauce like what that's very day delicious stomach teal
oh my god they let some random tick tocker get ahead of them
i literally how come you guys never invented food coloring
before i need i need oh man would you drink from the like
the cursed orange dye garfield cup radioactive garfield cup
the radio yes because it's garfield i mean like okay it's
just a little as long as i don't build it up you know Don't
don't do it continuously.
It should be fine, right?
Do it continuously.
Yeah, you know, you you have one you can like expose
yourself to radiation like once or some You get like a
freebie?
Yeah, like a scratch off like one free radioactive Yes,
exactly.
Yes, yes as long okay, it's like it's like a bestos, you
know, like
Like, you know, when you are exposed to bestows, you get,
you know, you get cancer, you get lung cancer.
But if you, you, if you don't continuously expose yourself,
you'll be fine.
You just, you know, go into, like, the house, like, for,
like, five seconds, you'll be okay.
Is that how it works?
You're just fucking dying.
It's like, it's like, as soon as you don't breathe in all of
it.
if you breathe it in god himself descends upon you and he's
like okay look when bananas have radiation it proves my
theory bananas have radiation in them that's not radiation
that's calcium no no no you didn't know that bananas have a
little bit of radiation potassium what what okay now you're
coping there's no like i i get california notifications
saying that everything i eat has Why would they not tell me
if bananas have fucking radiation?
It's just a little bit.
That's what I'm saying.
As long as it's just a little bit of radiation, it's fine.
A little bit of radiation as a treat.
Yeah, it's just a little, you know, a little treat.
See, so it's like, it's so tiny.
The drought is so fucking tiny.
But if you eat like 100,000 bananas, maybe it's not, maybe
then it gets a bit worse.
and bananas and then you'll die of raining You can I don't
can't connect to this fucking Okay Let me let me let me let
me let me walk you through So you click the bottom button
You click the little group of dudes The three little men
Yeah, I joined you Join me You type in the password in the
name So you see like I have the password And then I there's
the Person name Yeah What does it say?
It says Loading or something it just says like it just puts
me in the connecting forever and i had like oh my god i had
to like start it oh oh my god i know you wanted to talk
about radiated foods but my brain is fried i was gonna say
isn't it funny if you if with that logic you could like
sprinkle a little bit of radiation on each of your foods as
like a treat okay but like the thing is 100 acid bananas i
said you it one now you're trying it well imagine if you
separate it and you make it into a fraction so one banana
you could still have like a fraction of that banana yeah
yeah for bananas yeah i feel like you'll die by the time you
get radiation from bananas i think i think it's fine like
you there's no way you're gonna die from the radiation no no
there's no way you you eat enough bananas in your lifetime
to get radiation poisoning that's why that's why i'm saying
if there was a Garfield Cup like that's filled with
radiation I get one as long as I don't as long as I don't
pass the threshold to get radiation we're fine it was enough
radiation to make sure it was like never sold again though
like but I think maybe it was a lot okay but that happened
like a long time ago did anyone die from the Garfield Cup no
so we're fine if the people back then didn't die from the
also like did you start the thing because i still can't get
i think it's loading oh invited user it's an invalid
password what so i didn't fuck it up you fucked it up are
you did you put the password in correctly no i did i what do
you mean okay let me let me let me let me try again guys
we're professional streamers snuffy has been streaming maybe
even longer than me my anniversary is on 420 i'll be
streaming for four years oh dear i'm old snuffy has been
using this app definitely longer than me okay okay try now
see if that works please please is everything correct no it
says i got disconnected wrong password okay am i getting
what are you are you you using the right password i i think
wait there's no password in there oh wait i didn't put the
password in you're like simply i put it in right i just put
the name i just put the name you know the the dokey stuff
can't be wrong if i never inserted yeah exactly it can't be
wrong if i never poured in that password guys oh my i'm glad
like we're on the same wavelength here it's not my fault
it's just flip-flop between like who fucked oh my god jokey
jumpskin wait where are you oh there you are okay okay how
do i do this start bring your bottle okay so if you left
click you'll be in front yeah right yeah right click you
won't be in front so i could like okay all right here we go
we're figuring this out we're figuring this out okay wait i
should be taller oh yeah how can i canonically are you tall
are you a tall one i'm like eight feet tall
okay all right yeah yeah this is this is this is canon hype
by the way guys just
wait wait that means you're like seven feet you're not seven
feet you're smaller oh my god I'm literally that feels right
yeah I scream anymore
That's right.
This is my stream now.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Let me, let me, okay.
Here we go.
We're doing this.
It only took us a while, but we figured, guys, we're only 25
minutes.
Actually, no, we're only 30 minutes late, guys.
It's okay.
I think it's been, I think it's been great.
This is a mid-40.
Yeah, it's, this is fine.
guys are only 30 minutes late but look at the content now
you know about radiation in bananas you know watch your
banana intake guys yeah yeah and to all you kids out there
who's watching me get the fuck out yeah and your banana
intake as well kids yeah it's not a joke it's serious yeah
as many bananas you want you won't get radiation poisoning
if you see Garfield on a cup just walk away no just take one
sip and you'll be fine you get one drink we all get one you
know we all get to pick our radiation would that be like
your final like if you were on like death row and they're
like you get one last meal give me a fresh cup give me that
garfield cup i want all the food blended into the garfield i
want to know what radiation it tastes like i want to
remember garfield and red 40.
you didn't you know that like the reason why garfield the
garfield cup was filled with radiation was because of the
color orange yeah yeah because it was like oh i don't know
which combination poisonous color it was like orange and
green are like you need like radiation to make to make
orange and green back then because that happened for star
wars too where like they had to recall a bunch of star wars
cup because it had like orange and green in it oh what wait
like oh oh oh c3PO was it like a c3PO cup i have no idea i
just remember i just remember they have to recall a bunch of
star wars they're forbidden colors cadmium i'm on i'm on a
i'm on no year meme no year hey guys remember the funny meme
when people and kids were getting exposed to radiation so
fucking hilarious this picture says 1978 garfield it's not a
pretty life but somebody has to live at mcdonald's mug 99
000 ppm lead causes brain damage plus 5 830 m ppm cadmium
causes cancer so it actually wasn't even just cancer you
also get brain damage if you drink garfield how many but
like how much you have to drink though like what what what's
the limit before i get right that's really close to like
does one sip give me brain damage or was it like you know
several cups like we didn't know the numbers here i feel
like we should just we can't we can just have this like test
for ourselves like i'm surprised nobody's who you want to
drink like
it's content content yeah it's the cut mondays in my right
april fools happy monday i'm gonna drink five classes of
carfield cadmium you know like those like youtube videos
we're over there like uh taste like a tier list of which cup
has the most radiation radioactive glassware tier list
actually incredible tearless radioactive glassware which has
the most radiation come and find out as we taste as each
radiated cup i'm like swirling it around like we're trying
wine like oh yeah this one really resonates yeah i can taste
a little ready i can feel my brain like fuzzing up and then
like somebody get the those fucking like radiation testing
and then like the Geiger counter they had a Geiger counter
they're like all right chat let's see how much radiation
this cup has we gotta have like the fallout like rad noise
of just like
I can feel the lead already eroding my lungs I think that's
like an S tier right there what you think Did you eat lead
taste like it did?
Like, did you ever eat, like, pencil lead?
What?
Excuse me?
Look, I thought we were acting.
Now I'm not too sure.
Is this acting?
Is this?
Are we still...
Could you...
Could you explain your story?
Are you never sure?
No, no.
Judging by my reaction, absolutely.
What you, judging by reaction, what do you think?
I, I thought maybe it was a formative experience for many
people.
You know, when you're said school and you're bored, maybe
your pencil broke and you're like, oh, the letters just fell
out.
You know, it used to just like crack and I don't even
remember what possessed me to do it, but I feel like I was
like, well, let me just, let me just eat it.
I mean, it's crunchy.
It's like eating a tic-tac.
It was like really salty.
That's salty.
It was like sour almost like very chemically.
Oh my God.
People talk about glue eaters, but you're a fucking lid.
You're a smoker.
Yeah, dude, I used to like lick it too.
After like I started eating it, I used to like, every time I
used to start writing with a pencil, I would like lick it.
I would like suck.
I feel like you would be like one of the students.
my mom would be like, you shouldn't hang out with her.
Sorry, like, I saw people in like movies, they always like
writers like lick their pen or something.
They like dab their pen, I think, to like get the ink
flowing, but I didn't understand what that meant.
So I would just start like doing that with like pencils.
So I would just like dab the pencil onto my tongue.
I mean, like, dads are, but like you actively consume the
graphite, don't you?
do i just kind of started gnawing on all parts of it i think
i got a little bit of the paint as well
i'm chewing on eat it you know i think you are the perfect
person for the tier list yeah yeah we should just have like
a toxic product tier list where do you think we should put
the recalled the recalled products tier list oh god the
cursed consumer reports what's the best food, dude.
Should they recall it?
It would be like, so by our judgment, yes, they definitely
should have recalled it.
It could be one of them YouTube videos where it's like, now
you have to guess which one is which, and we'll be like,
okay, this one is definitely the recalled.
I can taste.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What?
Five items are on the table.
Three have been recalled.
It is up to Snuffy and Doki to find out which three were
recalled for containing lead.
You're like, I'm going to get emails reaching out to me
like, you know what?
I think you'd be great for factory work.
Do you want to like test some of our product going on?
Like, you want to be a taste testing.
Like the product testing.
Quality insurance.
You can pay for that too.
I know, maybe I get benefits.
Thank God.
Yeah.
I like how we have yet to play Roblox.
Yeah, maybe there's, maybe there's cadmium tasting Roblox
game.
Hey guys, you guys like this, this black screen.
So we got, we got distracted by, it started, it all started
with the rate, the Garfield Cup.
I don't even know how it started.
I think we were trying to, you know, there's like, there's
like, you can actually buy radiation items in like, like
those like, what was it, those donation stores.
goodwill what like is that is that what they're called in
america the goodwill stores yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
the second hand stores because like i there was a youtube
short i get all my information from youtube shorts nowadays
but like but like there's there's this like channel that
gets like a gaiga county and they go to like goodwill and
they like find all the items
Dude, oh my God, I actually, okay, so I actually probably
have something that's good for this, because it's good for,
good for poisoning myself.
When I became like independent, I was like, you know what a
big thing about becoming an adult is, is like owning plates.
So I went to like a secondhand store to buy some plates.
And I was like, oh man, these ones are so cute.
And they're like vintage.
That's so cool.
That should have been a warning sign.
My plates are from like 1938.
Good.
Like Googled it.
I was like, oh yeah, what, how plants are these and it told
me that like they're at like high risk like anything 1950 or
earlier is like do not consume because it's probably filled
with lead you know so i've i've got like tons of lead yeah
tons of wait have you wait you've actually consumed lead no
no well i mean other than from the pencil i'm then too
afraid to use them i feel like i'll just have to serve it to
my greatest enemy oh so they're just there for decoration
type deal yeah yeah i bought like a to ever eat from them
but maybe i should like okay how many subs in like a little
class oh my god before the fta was even funny invented holy
i'm gonna be good dude i'm good i'm great which would
suspend you have you had to i mean like listen to that like
self-harm
on a Twitter account, SnuffBee has been bad.
Oh, no.
That'd be way better than half of the bams, though.
I'd be so proud if I got banned from drinking from a lead
glass rather than like showing us.
I'd break the norm for VTubers at the first VTuber to get
bad for fucking drinking lead.
That's incredible, honestly.
Knowing the track record for VTubers.
Oh, man there's a first for everything and i'm here to see
it dude guys just remember if you think you have a plate
that's really really old make sure maybe don't use it
because most likely back then they use lead or uranium to
make the glass away is uranium the green one there's another
green one yeah uranium is a green one yeah yeah okay okay
because i was wondering that's the one where they oh yeah
people go to the secondhand stores and they have like the
light right yeah they shine the light and see if it i did
that because they had a couple of them and i was like i kind
of want that i feel like that'd be fun you never know when
superman might show up and you got to like neutralize them
yeah weakness the green crystal the green the kryptonite you
mean the kryptonite i'm just like bro you're right it
doesn't do anything to superman it's Look, they might be
both be green, but they're not the same thing.
I thought that was real.
This dog is named Crypto.
Why would you name your dog, like your weakness, like a gun?
Like, imagine naming your cat, like...
This is like the most badass thing ever.
Because it's like, this is the only thing that can hurt me.
Oh, my God.
I mean, I would name a dog gun.
I think that's cool They like naming also like people who
named their pets after like like real people named like if
you name your dog like Jerry or something hey
Where's Jerry Where's Jerry?
It's something you're talking about, like, you don't know
where your stepdad was.
Oh, man, where'd Jerry go?
I'd miss that guy.
But it's like an eight-year-old fucking, like, beagle
walking in and being like, Oh, yeah.
He's like, who's a good boy, Jerry?
You're my good boy, Jerry.
That's right.
Oh, my God.
Roblox, right?
Oh, yeah.
Roblox.
Anyway, what's the...
Roblox?
first roblox game you're gonna take me i've guys i've only
managed to play two roblox games or maybe three oh yeah i
played hospital rp um that's my favorite one oh my god i'm
hanging in i played hospital rp doors and the warrior cats
role play okay okay so like um snuffy apparently is like a
professional when it comes to roblox she has two accounts my
personal account for for my formative experiences and then i
have my work account for my business expensive business
expensive you go to a tax guy and you're like and um i spent
50 here for road bugs but it's a business expense because it
was for stream yeah that's how i felt about my gotcha games
is like my accountant would be like okay can i see your bank
statements and i'd just be like listen if you see five
hundred dollars for cookie run kingdom then like just close
them just you know just so you know just so you know i
streamed the content so it was a business expense this was
for stream i was planning this for a sponsor it was um work
related
i see okay so most engaging on the on the um the list so
just let me know if you see a game that interests you at all
because you know relax is pretty fun i like it a lot for
just being able to like hop in hop out be like oh you know
this was fun to try let's try something yeah yeah yeah if
you see something that like catches your interest let me
know um we've got some classics natural disaster survival is
a great game super fun but it's not cursed what are you
looking for what's okay what's your interest surprise me
like you're the expert here you're supposed to take me to
this like wild tour like oh my gosh you're like my pixie
manic girl and you're gonna take
girlfriend takes you to raise a peter on roblox let's go my
life changed when i met my pixie manic girlfriend okay okay
bro you have a hairstyle yeah this is a pixie manic guy from
berserk that's what i can't stop hearing everybody's like oh
nice griffith hair bro what the fuck is a griffin bro what
the fuck is a griffin what is a griffin i know i don't the
only thing i know about berserk is the is that scene i
should laugh about that scene wait what what what scene i
know about berserk because it's so up it's that scene
everyone people who know about berserk knows exactly what
scene i'm talking about i don't know anything about berserk
other than there's a guy named griffith and then people say
i look like griffith and then somebody said my final fantasy
14 character look like casca that's all i know and then got
people I just know about the horse yeah yeah everybody in
China saying the horse yes the horse that's the no no you
would not be laughing when you know what the scene is it's
so fucked up I like horse related content would this be good
or bad okay what do you think if people are like oh no a
horse what there's where does your mind go to my little pony
okay That's the other spectrum.
What's the other side of that?
What's the other...
So in the face of this keyboard.
Here you sit on this fucking pony spectrum.
That's one...
That's like one end.
That's the left side.
Where do you think the right side of that other side is?
For guiding horses.
Actually, I shouldn't.
I don't feel like I should be talking about this.
Just so you know.
There's a lot of ways that I can be worried right now.
That's...
That's not it's it's not a good scene.
I'll just say it's definitely not appropriate for Roblox I'm
pretty sure do not do not search it up Mads don't put me in
Roblox don't put me in the Roblox category.
They're not ready for me Just they were playing games and
demos.
Oh my god.
Okay guys, I know we haven't started the Roblox Street.
You know like Twitch contacted me to like headline more of
their Twitch rivals
What is this?
Because like they saw my schedule and they were like, yo,
Doki, do you want to headline the Roblox Twitch Rifle?
So Roblox Twitch Rifle is like just fucking invite me?
What?
I was like, are you gonna play?
Are you gonna play the shooting game?
Bro, I don't fucking know.
They were like, they're like, do you want to headline the
Roblox Twitch Rivals?
And I was like, bro.
I don't play Twitter.
I don't play Roblox.
That's so fucking funny Oh, you should have had mine.
That's fucking fantastic No, no, you know what you might get
you might get a lot of children from that That's not a good
idea.
Yeah, that might be wrong audience When worlds glide.
I said there was screenshot.
I don't want to play this game But it like it keeps it's on
the front page and I really don't like the Twilight daycare
wait Is this where we're like babysitters?
Are we gonna?
like 20 babysitter games oh no i'll take you to the best
ones don't worry okay okay i take tell me when tell me when
okay guys the roblox content starts now for real yeah yeah
okay i'll take you to the first one this one's a classic i
know a lot of people will probably be wanting this one
because it's it's it's just so good so this is raise a peter
um raise a p oh i heard about this game you raised peter
griffin yeah yeah oh my god now you'll finally experience it
if peter What?
Oh, right.
I gotta, like, put the game on the screen.
Hold on.
Okay.
Open Roblox.
How do I find you?
I think it'll prioritize friends.
Oh, okay.
If we're friends, it should just put us in the same world, I
think.
All right, guys.
Roblox content actually starting now, for real.
I just saw you.
Sorry.
We had, like, a 45-minute podcast going in, but for real,
we're starting.
all right so if i click play then it'll go straight to you i
think so oh i've joined you yeah i see okay i'm gonna click
play before i show my screen all right oh wait actually i
shouldn't guys i have to select the lobby wait how do i find
your lobby i haven't selected it yet i'm trying to figure
out how oh here we go it has to be a window that's what it
is okay chat get out of my face Oh!
Quit hassling me, bro.
Okay, uh...
We move us a little lower.
I'm so confused.
I'm just, I'm just, I'm doing my own little stream thing.
I'm trying to put the game on the stream.
There's invite friends.
Oh, you can invite me, right?
Oh, oh, oh.
Yeah, yeah, okay.
Okay, is this good?
Is this good?
Okay, I think this is kind of centered.
centered at all okay you okay there classic classic
copywritten free music whatever the heck what is it called
copyright license free copyright license copyright free
copyright free okay i'm gonna create lobby title doki snuffy
lobby password i'll have it be the say god damn wait this
time i'll know the screen this time i'll definitely know how
to insert my password i'm gonna screenshot it okay okay it
shows on the stream just an appropriate lobby name okay yeah
don't got stuffy i literally just spent 30 on robux don't
get me back
oh royalty free that's what they say $30.
I need my Robux, man.
Okay, surely that... Wait, it just disappeared.
Okay.
Look, she's trying her best right now.
She's trying.
It keeps disappearing every time I...
She ain't gonna fight as a kid, guys.
Don't...
Please.
Your whole name is appropriate.
I don't know...
Please understand.
It's my name.
I hate speech.
There's no way!
Okay, this one...
This will be good.
That works.
Okay.
I almost read it out loud.
It's so fucking ridiculous.
Okay, you got invited me.
Oh, I see you!
Yeah!
Wait, I don't know if that's the right one.
No, okay.
It should say dokey snuffy.
Yeah, yeah, I saw that name.
Okay.
Uh...
Yeah, yeah, I'm in!
Yeah!
Alright, alright guys, we can finally show the screen now.
It took us, it took us a while!
I think this is it, right?
Please use windowed or deck- Wait, what?
Is it this window?
Are you using windowed mode?
Yeah, I am.
Okay.
You do slowly- Oh, oh yeah, are you- capture the game?
Wait, wait, give me a sec.
It says, please use window...
Guys, we are going through some technical difficulty.
Wait, what's the problem?
What's the problem?
Am I not in window?
Oh, wait.
Yeah, I am.
I'm in windowed mode.
Do you have to capture it as a window and not a game?
It didn't work as a game for me.
Oh.
Wait, how the fuck do you do?
Okay, wait.
I figured it out, guys.
I figured it out.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I did it.
I figured it out.
There we go.
Now we got it.
Okay, here you go.
Oh, there's our Peter.
There he is.
He's running around.
That's our child.
I'm so happy.
I accidentally zoomed in.
He's so big.
I'm so, give me a sec.
Because, like, my up key is.
Okay, here you go.
Guys, look.
It's our Peter.
It's our child.
Let me zoom.
Okay, here we go.
All right.
After many technical difficulties, we made it.
We finally played robots.
Hurry.
We finally made it.
We made it.
Yeah, we're playing a game.
Okay.
Peter slowly loses hunger over time.
Buy burgers to keep him alive.
You can buy burgers at the gas station across the road.
Wait.
Oh, there's me.
Guys, am I beautiful?
You look great.
You look like you'd be the most thirsty character on a
horror video or something.
Oh my gosh.
That's great.
Oh, wait, he's dying.
Or Peter's dying.
No, he's only 10.
Oh, he's slowly losing health.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What do we do?
How do we save it?
Oh, watch how we're crossing the road.
The cars won't stop.
Will we die?
Oh, I did it.
Oh, nice.
What a giant!
What the fuck, you killed me!
What the fuck?
I did it again.
Bro, okay.
Maybe I should cross the road, too.
I shouldn't have single step.
I should have...
How the fuck did you die?
Okay, I bought two burgers.
Okay.
Boy gear.
Let's purchase pork gear.
How do I purchase?
I'm trying to purchase.
I got what?
Stealing is a Lego.
Oh!
I'm sorry.
I didn't know.
I thought I bought it.
I'm gonna die.
is my last day alive we have to die from cardiac arrest how
do I, how do we buy burger I gotta like, I gotta like mute
and like cough horrendously how do I, okay wait I got this,
I buy burger burger?
Oh, there you go alright, we lost a lot of money but I
bought the burger guys, hey would it be so wrong to like I
gotta like tinkle really before i laugh so hard it's not
gonna be it's okay i'm gonna feed our peter oh my god peter
don't worry i got it i bought i got the food i'm filling it
up burger refills 25 of peter hunger in addition to buying
burgers you can buy items from the peter net what do i do
with the peter net okay see open door guys i'm exploring oh
my god i can buy a phone guys i'm gonna spend my money
because snuffy is not here to stop me there are basics of
peter raise a peter there's a lot more to explore so have
fun okay i got phone for my peter what does that do peter
you have friends what are you gonna do call your friends
peter peter peter what does he do with the phone
Instructions unclear!
Freaking sweet little Liz.
Alright guys, I can't- Oh!
I got to unbox!
Alright.
No, wait, no, no.
Did I actually donate it?
Oh no.
Did I- Okay, no I didn't.
Okay, thank God.
I- I don't want to donate money.
Oh, is this the phone?
Call somebody.
I need to- gives you his money.
can call i called joe swanson yo snuffy i spent all our
money oh we didn't even i spent all our money on a phone
peter is hungry but the fridge is empty peter's starving
don't keep that but i got us a phone look i got joe i got
joe he's gonna give us money i robbed him how do i dynamite
okay Peter, hey, Peter, give me all your money.
You should raise your, how much, okay, give me all your
money.
Look, see?
Give me all your money.
He now makes $120.
Oh, my God, I can buy so many burgers now.
Go buy burger.
Are Peter dying?
He has 24 health.
Oh, my God, okay, I'm bringing it.
I'm bringing it.
Don't fucking die from the car.
We only have a dollar left.
There's no car this late at night.
Okay, I got, safely crossing.
Don't worry, I got like...
Don't worry, I'm gonna go buy more burgers too.
Oh my god, he's so close to death.
Yeah, he's so close to dying.
Don't worry, I'm picking it up.
Peter, Peter.
Okay.
Here you go.
I need another, I need another $25.
I don't know how to drop items.
I actually picked up a lot of items.
You robbed the store and got all of those items?
Stuffy, I need $25.
Stuffy, I don't know how to drop my items.
Oh, okay, okay, wait, wait, wait.
Peter will bless us.
Peter.
What do I do?
There we go.
I clicked him and he gave me money.
Oh my god.
If you click him, he gives me money.
It's like cookie clicker.
Okay, wait, wait.
Um, you want to...
Toki?
Toki, I heard a gun.
Everything's okay.
I just...
We got it.
Oh, we...
I'm going to go buy more burgers.
It's your egg.
I'm going to buy more burgers.
Don't worry I got us another burger.
I got us two burgers.
Don't worry.
I'm doing it Well, I'll make sure our Peter grows up big and
strong You got to click him for money.
I can I can have endless money now.
Oh, it's like cookie click.
It's like those AFK arenas Yeah All right, don't worry Hey,
oh you can call people.
Yeah.
Wow.
Yeah, yeah.
So I'm filling it up Okay, I got another all your money rate
you should raise your income okay 250 we need 250 dollars
wait do i click him yeah just click him and he'll start like
shedding okay okay okay we should we both click him at the
same time will we get like oh yeah look at the double the
double fingers oh we should get an auto clicker i'm i'm
getting a macro right now get a macro right now get the
macro Roblox didn't say anything about no macro.
Oh my god.
Don't worry, I'm clicking, I'm clicking.
Okay, we have more burgers.
Okay, so like...
We want to save $100.
What can we get with this money?
Don't worry, guys.
I'm a professional when it comes.
I'm okay.
Don't go outside.
Okay, look at you.
They're driving.
They're so outside.
I just see like a blowing off explosion sound effects and
then particles burst into the windows.
How do I get up?
Are you in like a coma?
I'm afraid to cross the road.
Pick me.
Rest me.
Steppy.
Real quick.
Oh my god.
You just feast out of the dirt.
Pick me up.
No, if he's a solution, I can't.
I think I'm...
Let me see if I can...
Maybe I can buy, like, a defib or something from the store.
Oh, I just need a jump.
Okay, I'm good.
I can get gasoline.
Cool.
You want to...
We can have a drink together.
Wait, what is it for?
What are the matches and the gasoline for?
Wait, there's, like, ammo?
Wait, you played this game before.
Why is there ammo?
I don't know.
I didn't...
I've only like glued the game up.
Peter is hungry.
Oh, God damn it.
Freedom of the Minecraft forge.
Oh, wait.
Okay, um, I need you to buy the burger for Peter.
Are you, you're on a wanted list?
I can't, I can't drop my matches.
I can't drop.
How much are the matches?
Okay, okay.
He said backspace, but it's not dropping.
How do I drop?
I actually do not.
know if you can drop items in roblox i've never i never knew
that i'm pressing backspace you're liars it's not backspace
i just oh my god i'd win i'd win against the car let's just
let's just okay i'm not going outside i'd fucking win let's
be honest trash can i can throw in trash okay i did it all
right i'm gonna is peter okay he's okay all right don't
worry i'm gonna buy more burgers then okay he's good he's
eating he's healthy okay i just realized we don't have a lot
of money so let me uh throw we have a lot of money now look
at that 30 30 bucks okay which one is the one i bought i
gotta milk him really quick you're gonna milk your peter
remember to milk your peters guys wait did i oh i already
bought this don't worry i'm going through i'm good at
crossing the road are you look i made it It's just like how
I know when you're coming home because I just see your
explosions.
It's okay.
It's okay, Peter.
I got you without food.
Can I call somebody else?
Wait, we should call his wife.
How much does his wife cost?
Like his, how much?
His wife is only $250.
We're gonna make that in no time.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, our Joe makes $258.
Okay, Peter, we're gonna call you.
wife we're gonna buy your wife buy her yeah like those mail
order brides buy her no not yet we need oh we can buy buy we
can get a mail order bride two times money and buys burgers
for us oh nice oh we don't have to do it anymore oh now
we're getting two two dollars per peter click oh my god wait
how did you promote your peter it's because of lowest it's
the lowest buff oh the lowest bub look at that guys when you
get a wife you can make two dollars per second
minus 10 sanity but two dollars per second right here i want
to just click on her dude fuck peter oh my god louis is here
wait she's leaving why is she leaving wait does she go buy
burgers she's gonna buy burgers for us oh my god we don't
have to do this anymore we've been promoted to just clicking
Don't worry, Lois, we'll milk Peter for you.
Oh, hello?
Hello?
The doorbell?
Who called us?
Hello?
Wait, who's that?
Who's walking down the street?
Wait, what is that?
What is that?
Wait, that's a prank caller!
We just got fucking...
We got...
What do they call that?
Door dash?
Yeah, we got, like, ding-dong dash.
Door dash is the fucking Uber Eats.
Oh, God.
or dash.
Peter.
Hey.
It's your favorite family guy character.
My favorite family guy character.
I think my favorite family guy character.
Oh my gosh, that's so difficult.
There's so many.
You remember that one dog that was there because they baited
us when Brian died?
The Italian dog?
Yeah, I wanted to like do a scarf or something.
did you see that did you see that post where like some guy
got a fucking tattoo of brian to like like as like in
memoriam for him and then and then the day and then the day
after like brian was like not dead what do you think he
tells people now like about his tattoo of in memoriam brian
in like 19 like what was that like 2016 or something oh yeah
yeah that's like that's so smart though because like he
because like stephanie farland was like we need more ratings
let's let's do a fake out like pretending to kill out brian
that's i feel like i felt the impact back then i don't know
what it was you're like you didn't but when i was a kid i
think i had a crush on him i don't know why crush on a dog
well I don't think that was part of it I think I like I like
that he was like a free thinker I was like yeah you know I'm
an atheist I'm in middle school that's cool I don't know I
thought he was cool yeah no no don't say that no no that's
not and he's a dog no no no I want to give him a swirly in
the toilet no now you're just making stuff up Yeah, you're
just, oh, no, you got caught.
I'm being honest with my life, and you say I'm making it, I
don't know if I should, I should be, like, honored that,
like, my stories are that, like, oh, it's so, like, fables.
Well, it's not just, not that, it's the fact that, like, him
being a dog was not, like, the main, one of the reasons why
you had it.
who have like crushes on like what what's his name cobu from
the lion king i bet you were one of those kids that had a
crush on cobu weren't you no it was like you are projecting
that sounds like you know from experience no no no snuffy
did you had a crush on cobu as a no no but the girl lion
could get it though yeah yeah yeah what's your disney crush
snuffy what's my greatest Okay, my real true, like, Disney
crush, I like Esmeralda or Megara from Hercules.
Those are my Disney crushes.
Those are my girls, yeah.
Beautiful women.
The women.
What about the males?
Who are the, who are the male crushes?
Disney men?
Now tell me there's a Disney man for you.
Like, tell me.
Any, any male characters in Disney.
Oh, and it has to be.
Is there even, like, a memorable one?
It has to be.
Why is Lois not doing her fucking job?
Gaston's pretty dope.
I like that guy.
Gaston's pretty nice.
He's cool.
Get yourself.
Yeah.
$1,000.
What are we going to do with this?
Call his friends.
Wait, oh, wait.
We can buy stuff on the Peter net.
The Peter net.
We can give him a couch.
I'm buying him a chair.
And then I'm buying...
him uh wait like wait what there's like a couch oh i'm
buying him a chair i'm buying two couches okay there's
somebody like taped to our ceiling and then i'm gonna buy
wait okay now we're broke now we're broke wait i can call
more people there's somebody there's somebody about like
taped on our seat there's somebody taped on our ceiling
where is that oh shit what the fuck is that stuff I ordered.
I ordered a couch.
Here she comes.
Here's my coach.
Wait, I ordered two couches.
Where are my two couches?
There.
One of the...
He's gonna give us like three dollars now.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, now four dollars because I ordered two couches.
Oh, two couches.
It's turning into the family guy.
Alright, keep clicking.
I'm gonna talk to Joe to give me money.
Six dollars.
Oh my god.
Holy crap.
Joe makes $500 now.
this is it this is a give us your money peter this is it you
give us your fucking money we can call his child soon i'm
gonna give us your money peter all right i'm gonna go call
yeah have you seen like steph mfraudner's newest show ted
this tv yes yes i've seen it i've seen it three times wait
like no not the movie the tv show yeah yeah i love it what
do you think i do i all i do is like i i each crotch and
watch a seth mcfarland tv show that's gonna do for like
eight hours a day yeah your entire personality is based off
of seth mcfarland's show do your do your can you do a a
family guy impression like what character do you think you
can do the best okay definitely joe That's the only one I
can do.
Hey, Peter.
I called Brian, by the way.
I didn't always, but I don't, I haven't practiced in a
while.
Oh, show it, show me.
Show me your, your impression.
Shit.
How do I even do that?
Okay, hold on.
Let me, let me mute and like practice really quick.
Can you just mute and practice?
I did a Peter right off the bat.
You need to say, Peter.
great though like i'm trying to try hard i'm like
auditioning are you trying to see why joe swanson was not
good enough is that it was great it was great but that's
like a liberating thing to say like who wants to like show
off as lois who wants to be like oh man i love lois Brecken.
Brecken!
Wait, wait!
Wait,
wait!
Brecken!
Oh my god, he just shit on the floor!
No, we gotta get- we gotta get Sto- we- we're- I'm gonna
call Stoey so that Stoey can eat the shit.
Is that what that happens in- Yeah, I just...
Well, you don't know your fucking...
You don't know...
Oh!
You don't know your fucking fam, and you call yourself a
Stefan Farland fan.
Where's Stewie?
Stewie, Stewie's here.
He's gonna eat the shit now.
What?
What the fuck?
There's so much shit.
Stewie, get on the fucking floor.
Stewie, do your job!
Stewie.
Oh my God, he ate shit for $400.
Okay, that we're fucking rich.
All over his face.
Oh, we're fucking rich now.
This is it.
We're making money.
We're raising Peter.
Okay, let's see.
Aha.
Okay, we need a TV for our Peter.
Oh, I got TV!
He's only aged two.
That doesn't seem very old.
Okay, we got TV and then we got a, we got another friend.
Nice.
Wait, two fridges?
Double the birds?
Yeah, double the birds.
Okay, let me talk to Joe and threaten him for money.
Okay, he doesn't want to give us money yet.
Okay, the TV's here.
The TV.
We're getting the TV.
The TV is here?
Nice.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Here we go.
I'm packing it.
It's beautiful.
Look at that!
Are Peter's gonna grow up big and strong?
Hey, what's this other box?
I don't know.
What did I...
Oh, the fridge!
The fridge!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Guys, guys, you think we're doing a good job raising our
boy?
He's happy.
He's so happy.
We're giving him a family.
We're buying him a family.
If Lois worked harder, he would be even happier.
I like how Lois was cheaper than his child.
He's not the truth, dude.
A strong...
Guys, every family needs a strong Peter foundation.
strong peter hey peter hey peter i want to check the
internet the peter net the petronet where you're gonna get
from the peter net it's only 50 for a nice rug why not like
let us stay warm and cozy yeah but does it oh there's a
brick what do we do he's taking my stuff how the fuck oh he
took a chair he took the chair i don't know what to do
you're a you're a a gun for there's so many these two
there's two of them they're taking everything we buy a gun
how do we buy a gun how do we get a gun from the store we
need to protect ourselves our first is it the first
amendment i don't know i'm not i thought that that's like a
freedom of speech or something you're saying you're american
oh it's our second amendment we need to
We need to get a gun.
How is I supposed to know which amendments?
How many amendments do you guys even have?
Amendments.
Wait, 12?
That was like a religious thing.
What?
That's the amendment.
Like the 12 commandments or something?
They're back.
I'm getting the dynamite.
I'm going to go buy dynamite.
They're back.
Where are they going to steal?
It's the whole house or nothing.
Like they're not.
If they take everything we have.
I'm getting matches and dynamite.
of my i don't know what fortnight battle pass i've got the
fortnight battle pass i don't know he didn't reference even
viable anymore he's the solar table and our tv wait what the
fuck did i paid for it you 500 dollars i paid for it i paid
for it he kicked me i paid for it i'm getting robbed on both
ends how do we where where's the gun where is it where's it
saying an amendment.
Okay.
I'm leaving with the dynamite.
I'm getting another.
I'm getting another chair.
I'm getting chairs.
We can get robbed?
At any moment, I'm ready.
We're robbed.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
Let me know.
And we're going out.
We're going out.
Just let me know.
I'll let this whole thing.
Oh, okay.
No, no.
That's just our chairs again.
I got us chairs again.
Oh my god.
The storm is so scary sounding.
I got us more chairs.
Oh, yeah, maybe...
Wait, they took our phone.
What?
Wait, they took our phone?
We can't call anybody.
We took the fucking phone.
Okay, apparently, if you close the door, you can't get
robbed.
You know, that's actually a good idea.
You can just leave our door open.
You're so irresponsible.
We're irresponsible.
This is a group effort here.
We can't have...
We are both responsible for our peters.
for Peter.
He might wander outside.
He might walk outside and get hit by a car.
How could you do this to our son?
Okay, wait, let's see.
Why do we buy a new phone?
Oh, I got pier.
We can fish now.
Somebody said in the Razor Peter meta, did you know there is
a Razor Peter meta, and they said that we should grab a
fishing pier?
If we want to be very efficient in raising our Peter, we
need to get a peer.
Just remember to close the door.
Don't worry, guys.
I'm going to close the door.
Guys, do not worry.
It's not just about raising Peters.
We're just...
No, wait, wait, wait.
It's kind of like you walked away.
Did you close like a real door?
Yeah.
But I got the fishing pier.
Where the fuck is the pier?
Oh, oh, the fishing pier.
I thought you said the fishing Peter.
I was like, we get double the Peters.
Wait, where the fuck is it?
Like a fishing thing.
Yeah, I'll try crossing the road.
Where's our fishing thing?
I saw it like show up on my street.
It's across the street.
Why is our thing across the street?
Oh!
Oh no.
Fishing rod.
You got a fishing rod.
How do I get one?
Don't go outside.
Can I aim?
I'm fishing.
I'm going to fish.
Okay.
We must.
Just be careful.
Is it coming to the house?
Oh, it's getting delivered.
Oh, it's getting delivered?
Okay.
Well, I'm going to close the door soon.
I don't want to get robbed again.
I have...
We don't have a gun yet.
We haven't practiced our Second Amendment yet.
what did you i got something is it a fishing rod did you get
i don't know it went to without fishing pier oh nice nice oh
i could get the chicken and i could get quagmire and i could
get meg why is chris the most expensive what is what why the
is chris griffin so expensive compared to everybody is it
because is it because seph green does nfts I'm a little
confused it says that you can buy a pier so so like a cover
so rain and thunder won't kill you Oh, yeah.
Yeah, that's what happened to me I like how someone's like
Chris's end game Oh, yeah, Chris Griffin.
Yeah, that's kind of end game Yeah, that's end gink Oh, Meg
dries off burglar because she's ugly Is this quagmire?
Why is he a toilet?
Is he a toilet?
Oh, no Oh, the chicken!
Oh my god, we're making so much money!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
He occasionally turns into a toilet, gives two times money
while toilet.
Oh, he gives more money!
Wait, does that mean if I, if I, like, click him?
He gives me money?
No, it's, like, automatic.
It's for Peter, yeah.
It's like a Peter buff.
So, like, I mean a Peter buff.
So, like, if, like, Quag...
If, like, Peter sits on the Quagmire toilet, we get money.
Yeah, he gets extra milk.
We need to get Endgame.
We need 5k or 7k.
for end game we got all click on peter i still don't i
bought a fishing rod but i can't use it unless you haven't
no i have nothing in my do you know where the pier is maybe
it automatically oh maybe you go you go you go over to the
you go over and fish i'm gonna try it snuffy did you
You saw him, didn't you?
I saw him.
I'm trying to feed outside and I saw him.
I got a vision.
I'm not sure if it was real or not.
All right.
I'm trying to get drinks coffee for a short speed boost.
Why do you need speed boost for?
Can boost your money up to $5?
four times oh my god i have more stuff coming in guys bro
the factory is going oh my god we're we're fucking gonna we
can finish this i think we can finish this game we can get
to end game give me all your money in the end game i think
it's like it's like a forever type of thing like you just
dedicate your life to racing your peter to it's like that
you know that kim gardashian game
do you know kim kardashian had like this like fucking
similar pre-raise of peter but for kim kard i'm i'm i'm
getting i'm getting assaulted by a ghost you're getting
assaulted by i'm getting a fish and there's fucking ghosts
there's a there's a ghost i can't go inside or the thunder's
gonna get me it's only attacking me during the if i'm close
to the fish pool it says like snuffy accepted a quest me
phones dead what did you accept he wants a he wants an eel
but if i fish i start getting like attacked yeah wait but it
says like me quest you accepted a quest though quest me
quest me phone's dead hi oh my god i'm gonna die i can't
ever ever since i got like struck by thunder i can never go
out again i live i'm gonna be a neat i got hit by thunder
and now i'm gonna be a neat forever maybe i have to do this
during the day or else i'm gonna get like harassed by like
ghost visions of when has it been wait i'm gonna turn on the
speaker what does the speaker do
yeah dance
How do I use my emote?
Why?
Is this a stereo system?
Yeah, I bought this.
$30, Peter.
Guys, how do I use emote?
I bought an emote with my $30 robux.
An emote?
I think you got to equip it.
Did you equip it?
Yeah, yeah, I did.
How do I use the emote, will you?
How do you use emote?
Uh, e-dance?
E?
Wait, slash, aren't you gonna e-dance?
Oh, you gotta, like, type it?
E-dance?
Slash?
I don't wanna type.
Oh, wait.
I think everybody's gonna laugh at me in the chat now.
Oh, you're saying you should prevent you from sending...
Guys, I put...
You guys, I don't have a chat because I got scared.
Guys.
Guys, is there a way to activate it without type?
Oh, shit!
way to activate what typing oh press period okay period oh
there it is look oh shit i have the stadium what this cost
me 90 robux okay show it to me whoa
i spent 90 robux on are you proud of me i spent real life
money this is where your money goes to dragoons in real life
money i don't know what you're talking about
guys this is where your money goes to i have lil nas x old
town road what the how much did that cost mine was 90 robux
actually i got this from the live lil nas roblac Wait, there
was a little NAS ROFOX concert There was a ton of them.
There was like 21 pilots of like No shit cat or something.
No, no, I think it was Nikki but Nikki but Nikki Manage has
like pussy world It's like the Nikki Manage pussy world.
They actually okay This might be a little on the on the on
the on the on the point here There was a world that was
actually in a Roblox sponsor, but it was removed because it
was still a little bit adult for them, but it was basically
like a woman's...
What to call this?
A woman's menstrual and like informational world where you
could change your character model to like a woman's tampon
and like go down the tubes and all those pieces, parts and
like get a whole like informational like it was practically
think of it as like a magic school bus like you shrink down
and get to experience like the the the parts of a woman in
roblox how did you how did you know this did you go there
did you visit this world but it got fucking removed for
being mature world you visit every day today let's it's time
to visit the menstrual world i'm roblox i just really like
to be a champ on one day Oh my god.
I wish it still lived to this day, but I definitely think
there might be like a YouTube video that like goes in depth
on like how cursed it.
Oh!
You can like, you can roleplay being like, like let me see,
hold on, let me see if I can like send you something in
Google that shows it.
Wait, the sex update went through on Roblox?
Is that true?
Is that, is that true?
Are there AT plus servers now, Roblox?
Oh my god, it was called V-Land.
The V-Land?
I don't even, don't like, boot this up because I don't know
if it's the real one, but like, this is what it looked like.
V-Land, we get to dress up as, like, a taff.
Oh!
I go to the menstrual sleep.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna save this and put it on stream so you
can see me.
Oh my god!
What am I looking at?
What?
Oh my god!
This is...
Oh my...
Now I know why they shut it down.
I love...
Now I know...
I like these like thumbnails from YouTube that if you search
like Roblox if you land just get these relics of like what
could this possibly be you guys in my mod don't don't link
it in chat let's let my mods if you don't link it in chat
let the chat discover it themselves let them discover my god
wolf this is so good wait i gotta save this picture this is
so good i want to make this like my fucking collab just
chatting picture yeah you can't think
It's not a real thing.
What?
It is.
That was 100% a real thing.
That was very real.
I can't fucking believe it.
It's just another Roblox classic moment.
Like...
I don't even have any words to describe how I feel learning
about this.
Oh my god.
There's like, I can't.
I can't comment.
the bathroom again i can't i can't even commentate on this
like what like this is like beyond my pay grade the game is
still up the game still exists i thought it got taken down
what do you mean it's still around i've been raising my
peter this entire time i'm gonna end this game i'm gonna i'm
gonna end this game
it's gone too far i am ready i'm ready to buy this
mysterious burger what do i pay for it hello oh there you go
five thousand oh wait i can five thousand dollars not bad
okay i gotta throw this away we're not playing v land we're
not playing v land guys we we're not there's no there's in
no world where i'm gonna fucking play v land oh my god we
need to fucking grab 5k so i can end this we
I can't keep going on After learning about Beelan We're so
close We're so close to 5k We're almost there I don't need
to learn more about women Because women aren't real We had
this conversation chat Women were never real Not on the
internet Alright It's time It's time to end this.
I didn't even want one.
Alright.
I got the mysterious burger.
I have the money.
This is it.
We're gonna kill Peter.
Peter, I'm coming over.
This is gonna end now.
Where is he?
How do I feed him this?
Peter, eat this burger.
Wait, do I?
open oh he'll eat it when he gets there all right okay we're
good we it's just a waiting game and then we'll we'll kill
Peter okay okay I'm back welcome back snuffy yeah snuffy I
have end game ready oh shit we got we got we got Griffin son
number two I got number one I guess we Christmas been here
for like 10 minutes now, Snuffy.
What is it like me for?
Chris has been here for...
He's the one that's been turning on the speaker on and off.
No, I thought that was you.
I thought you were... Do pizza?
Is this Endgame?
No, no, no, no.
Look, look, look.
I got the mysterious green burger.
Oh, the mysterious green burger?
The nasty patty?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The nasty patty.
Have you seen, like, modern SpongeBob?
Spongebob is still going on.
You're like so it's so much.
Yeah, it's so much.
Yeah I'm like scared.
I would rather watch like one of those like horrendous like
have you ever seen like that one adult swimsuit like mr
Pickles I would rather watch that like modern pops up in my
YouTube recommend I was like what the fuck is this?
I used it was like the only thing like on at three in the
morning and I used to like click on it Ironically watch mr.
Pickles are playing and then I would just be like jaw agape
the whole time I would be like 13 and just being like what?
That's so fucked out.
It's so gross Wait, there's so much money in our house.
Wait, Peter ate the green burger, but he's still what
happened?
He ate it.
What happened?
Oh, wait, what wait, did he glow?
Okay.
No, no, he just like pooped out of cash That's it what it
said ending
Where's the ending?
I got scammed.
I paid $5,000 for this.
$5,000.
Wait, what?
We have 66 feathers.
What does that even mean?
Oh, I bought a store.
Apparently there's like a chicken coop and then you like buy
stuff at the chicken coop.
Why is he still alive?
Oh, is this right next to our house?
Wait, there's some...
No, that's a cave.
King coop.
Upgrade.
Where's the chicken coop?
Scares.
Wait, where is it?
Oh, there it is.
There is no ending?
It's a forever.
Peter is like a...
It's a commitment.
Make Ernie punch 0.2 times faster.
Make Ernie punch.
Everything just makes him punch faster.
It just says make him punch.
I'm stuck.
There's a cave over here.
I see I found the cave.
What's inside?
Too bad it's blocked here.
The vine's need to fill up the gasoline meter.
meter you have to purchase gasoline tanks once you fill up
the meter you use a match to light up the vines now just sit
back once the cave is open grab oh my god what is this game
what did you get i'm stuck i can't stop i can't even stuffy
i can't even get out wait what wait what's happening is this
the ending did we did we beat the game wait what's going
what the fuck He dragged from the Garfield Cup.
Oh, he's dead.
I think I forgot to take...
You got the herring!
It's the Garfield Cup!
Oh my god!
It's the fucking...
I was kicked from the experience.
Oh my god.
God,
we gave him the Garfield Cup.
It all comes full circle chat.
Oh my God.
I can't believe it.
You want to try a different one?
Let's try a different one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's try another Roblox game.
Oh my goodness.
I can't believe it.
The Garfield Cup was real.
It was actually real.
Okay, okay.
uh let's see what what kind of game are you feeling now that
that was a good like get the get the blood pumping right
yeah that was a great one i can't believe we killed peter
there's you can have a hundred players in a fucking peter
lobby oh my god how do you stop like a hundred people from
not feeding him the uranium burger like i feel like i'll
just go straight to one and people's game.
He's going to like public lobbies and buy the uranium
burger.
I'm like, oh, fuck Bob.
So you said you've already been to like the hospital
roleplay before?
I did the hospital RP.
I've done Dora's and I've done Warrior Cats roleplay, but
I'm down to go back to the Warrior Cats roleplay.
Sometimes to go back to the Warrior Cats.
Have you ever, have you ever turned, like what I like to do
is i like to ask my friends to turn their vtuber self into a
warrior cat like into a warrior oh not like not my not my
vtuber self but i've done it as a kid multiple times okay
this one's a good one did you do this one this one's my
favorite one which one is it official because they have
official ones now i have an official one yeah yeah yeah this
is my warrior cats rp create your own uh in the official
game based on warriors yeah this is this is official this is
the one yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh nice nice nice it's
really good all right let's let me boot it up wait how how
many times have you played the official i've only played it
once how many times have you one time yeah i've done this
one time i don't know it seems like you were pretty
experienced just now there's bunches of them that's why
because i played i played a couple of them but this one i've
only played one time oh how do you know it's good if you
only played it once because that was just that phenomenal
all right apparently I actually have to install roblox for
this is how elaborate it is you don't have them for the
other no I didn't I didn't have to I actually have to
install roblox for the warrior cats roleplay all right
warrior cats okay let's see uh join friends all right wait
what server are you in oh that's you I see you you're the
cat yeah i'm a cat you're made for this oh my god the icon
is like two cats in love two cats in love all right settings
what the fuck is this show display name next to roleplay
name show use roleplay name in chat box if chatter this will
be a great place for you to spend some robux i'm sure let's
see character editor editing oh my god there's so many
there's so many like is this there's so many settings
there's a warm filter cool blue lights dropped item head
turning warning these settings will cause lag wind line okay
i'm gonna show this guys this is actually crazy look at look
at the affecting settings wind line shake effects on mobile
who the fuck is role playing on mobile this is a full pc
game all these fucking settings for my roblox rp okay now
i'm gonna hide it because i don't know what it what it's
gonna show okay play it's pretty safe so far i think the the
main thing is that your username might show every so often
but oh my god it's character creation time all right welcome
to the character creation this is where you can customize
your cats with colors and accessories you can change your
cat's color using the left panel you can use the paintbrush
to color you use the slider change the age i'm gonna be a
kitten i'm gonna be a i'm gonna be a kit yeah a little kit
so i'm gonna be a doki kit have you have you ever read
royale oh 100 until like it got way too convoluted i stopped
when when like you know like the three the three kits that
had like powers and stuff chosen three yeah the chosen three
and then one of them was a fake one like and then they found
out she's fake and then she ran into the cave because she
got so fucking emo about it and then she and then she fake
died and oh my god you've just most of it done at least most
of the good stuff yeah and then i stopped because i was like
what the is going on also like i was so tired because crow
feather was fucking every cat that showed up so
Whacking.
And then, like, cats started, like, fucking every other cat.
And then I lost track of which cat was fucking which cat.
I still...
I was so fucking confused at that point.
And then...
And then I stopped.
I just thought, you know, it just got too weird.
It just got too weird.
Crow Fedder, like, banged, like, four different cats.
And I was just like, bro, what the...
What the fuck is going on?
My brother is so fucked up.
Bro, like any cat that looks into his way and he's like, I'm
in love.
I'm in love now.
Like, I'm just like, bro, fuck off.
Touch starve.
And then like, I'm like, what?
What does this cat have that's like special?
He's like a little brat.
He's like a little bitch.
There's so many cats in this world.
What the fuck does crow feather has that like two medicine
cats were like I'm in love Like two medicine cats that's
like pulling in like the hottest girls at school like the
medicine cats Yeah, because like the medicine cats are like
it's like forbidden love because in war okay for those who
don't know It's like a clan thing so like there's like a cat
that's like the doctor and like they're like super religious
Because the dog like because they don't they don't fuck The
it's like super forbidden for the medicine cat yeah they're
like uh what are those girlies called a nun they're like cat
nuns they're like cat nuns so like they're they're like even
the the guys who the cat frees too they're not allowed to
they're not allowed to like have children or have like like
mates or whatever so like the thing is there's this one cat
that managed to get two different medicine cats to like fall
in love with him and bang and i'm like what does he have and
then after that he got two new cats To fall in love with
him.
So it's like, what the fuck?
Does he just have a big dick?
Like, what's going on?
Like, is this scent, like, super, like, attractive?
I don't understand.
And, like, I don't understand.
Like, does he have game?
How much thought you've put into, like, how attractive this
cat?
Like, I'm like, I don't understand.
Like, why does this cat keep banging other cats?
so many cats and then like i stopped reading it because i
was just like this is like i don't i i just really hate crow
feather i really that was so gross i want to push them
downstairs my cat my cat i always wonder about warrior cats
so then i look at my cat and like i was going to the
bathroom and she came into the bathroom with me and then she
just started gnawing on the doorstoppers
She's so smart.
My little killer.
I don't know what.
I can't try on any of these robux outfits.
I don't know.
How do I know if they're good or not?
You bought robux outfits?
Well, I have robux, but I haven't gotten an outfit.
But some of these are like, if you want, like, lovely
earpiece, that's 150 robux.
I'm going to be, oh, I'm going to be crow feather.
I'm going to be a black.
I'm going to be a crow feather.
You're going to have turning heads with crow feather
watches.
to turn heads like crow feather right now i mean this is it
this is i hate him but like if he has game then schemes
that's the word okay i'm gonna be a baby though oh my god
i'm so tiny you won't be i need to find a mom in a mom okay
i'll be how do i you said you're a kid yeah i'm a kid i'm a
kid okay i'm gonna load in as my cat gonna load in us your
cat oh you already have a cat yeah i got i mean i had a
quick kitty that i could make i don't know if there's any
too many options i want to check like oh ear tufts kitty
pets thunder clan there's nobody in thunder clan why is
nobody in thunder clan who the fuck even likes wind clan
that's like the most forgetful one yeah it's like river clan
thunder clan shadow clan and then the other one which yeah
oh i need to buy it try to buy the extra ear type so people
know I have cred I'm gonna buy I'm gonna spend I'm just like
kidding and the only person in thunder I'm gonna become the
leader I don't I'm gonna I'm gonna buy curled ears
what does it look like I don't even know oh my god it's so
ugly it's so ugly it's okay guys I need people to know I
spent money oh my god guys it's so ugly guys it's so they
have pansy earpiece left hearty butterfly wing pumpkin
flower luxurious body piece wait it's locked tier four
luxurious oh my god down oh my god oh you should see my cat
i'm giving them the like you know like the disney animal
smirk like the the bedroom eyes dreamworks yeah no no no not
the dreamworks but the bedroom eyes when disney this bedroom
eyes with the this the little the little like narrowed eyes
and you're like hey
i'm gonna give them the the the disney eyes oh my god you're
really just making the most fuckable excuse me i'm a child
i'm a i'm a child vine wraps i can what the hell spangles
and splotches Okay, wait.
What does that even mean?
The forehead diamond.
Oh, I would have a forehead diamond, so I'm special.
A forehead diamond.
Yeah, yeah.
You've got like a stripe bandana, stripe collar.
Normal muzzle, long muzzle, short muzzle.
It's 150 robux for short muzzle.
What does that even mean?
Leading heart necklace.
Let's see.
Oh my gosh, there's flowers.
There's spiky flower.
Painted ear leaves.
my gosh okay wait there's so many choices all right what are
the the paid ones the lovely earpiece what the is this like
the ruffled head 299 oh i see okay it's not so bad because
like you see how there's like the little like pink icon next
to some of these i thought you had to buy them individually
but if you buy something that has like i bought pink flower
one and you get all of the for that much money so like you
pay 300 to get like all of those items all right that's a
lot better yeah that's pretty good all right i'm just like
100 wait there's something for a 599 robux i'm buying this
guys give me a sec it's a fucking restock of robots i should
have never you don't understand oh my god okay guys guys
look look at this this was 599 robux this is
oh my god i literally just brought my chat back i was like
going crazy i was like wait where's my chat i thought i
deleted it dude i'm gonna get the chin tough i'm gonna be
like uh um oh my god bro i'm bro i'm gonna get all the
ladies when i outgrow my kit phase when i pass my kit phase
guys i'm gonna get all the ladies just you wait just you
wait okay let's see oh wait what's this tail streak the tail
the normal tail oh i want to have like a plum a plum tail
and then what's this cuff right okay okay sores there's vine
wraps there's so many accessories why i'm just buying them
all there's so many this is how they get you this is how
they get you it's totally it's totally you can make the
decision yourself you're strong you're strong i'm not i want
to be like i want to be crow feather oh no okay i got it i'm
done all right get let's put a thunder clan we'll populate
character we'll populate this okay where are you the only
one in thunder clan is that you the hud the bottom hud
buttons can be used to change clans okay this menu lets you
edit information about your character such as name and
description.
Okay.
You can check out the animation sitting.
Change your cloud allegiance.
Go to the other location or see a map.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Look at me.
I'm baby.
Wait.
I want to change my cat info.
I just don't care.
This kid is going to grow up and be a Fuck boy There you go,
did I save it?
Oh, I forgot okay this kid is going to grow up and be a Bad
a bad boy
This is me I'm the tiniest kid out there.
I can't believe no one wants to join Thunder clan Are you
breed pelts?
That's you.
Oh my god, you're breed pelts.
You're looking breed pelts.
A fucking course you are.
Dude, there's somebody else here.
Dude, look at our Thunder Clan.
What's already so populated.
We fucking populated.
There's so many fucking crop helps.
There's like five crow pelts here.
Breed.
Breed pelts, you did it.
You repopulated.
When you were a kid too, never mind.
I remind you also Wait, wait, size up, size up Size up, size
up You still says a kid It still says kid It says I should
be an apprentice Change rule, oh change rule Wait, oh nice,
so you can size down But you can change your rule too So you
can be Canonically a smaller cat if you wish How do you do
it?
Oh, just click on the bottom There's your cat info And you
can add like your canonical cat name And then you can add a
description like Super edgy.
Oh my god.
I'm a big cat.
I'm a big kid.
Just so you know there was something in my mama's milk that
made me like this.
Something in your mama's milk.
In the cadmium.
She's got the asbestos.
She lived in the barn attic and she got too much asbestos.
My cat mom was definitely taking something.
That's why I grew up big and strong.
Does your say, this kid is going to grow up and be a bad
boy?
Yeah, that's me.
Wait, what does your say?
I'm a bad boy.
We should visit the other clans.
I want to visit the other clans.
We can wage war on them.
I love how we're all just like black cats.
Like we've literally created the crowbell.
Wind clan was the Wind clan was the one that Had a lot of
people right Too many people they had it too good They had
it too good I'm gonna I'm gonna go in there I want to see
what are they role-playing right now Oh my god Very nice cat
and very friendly I'm so sorry A loyal and intelligent
feline That's their medicine cat Oh wait wait wait how do I
talk to these people Want to go play with their medicine cat
Hello I'm Joki from the leader leader from um meow from
thunder clan i'm lost the leader up front okay wait let me
i'm gonna be trying to find my mommy i was like look so
around i'm cranky wait i gotta i gotta now that i'm the
leader of thunder clan i gotta change my name canonically
from breed pelt to breed you're the leader I'm having a
conversation with with a fury oak wait what was this with
with the medicine oh no am I ruining this this poor child's
time trying to roleplay you gotta be cool you can be the
deputy or a queen do you know do you want to be the wetter
skin guy bro the medicine guy's like I don't know how to
help you do you know what look like no wait i should age
size myself down i'm so sorry child
was it stay far away from disgusting evil cats oh my god we
have suffered through many losses today we mourn the loss of
our past leader but tomorrow what the this is an actual
story going on stuffy the role playing is role play is all
about like it's like right oh my god there's so much
immersion you gotta we gotta be in character uh wait this is
high rock right so you gotta be like let me let me let me
get into my role play okay so if you go to If you go to
animations, you can do stuff too.
You can like hit it.
You can be like, let me break into my role.
You know, I actually used to do Warrior Cats roleplay on
Neopets.
I thought Hi Rock.
I actually used to do Warrior Cats roleplay on Neopets.
And my character was Wild Pelt.
I would do like OOC, you know, and then like, I had like
pre-built like character sheets built out.
for my my cat role play oh my god no fucking see i did the
same thing i don't know i didn't do warrior cats role play
but i think for a while i did like bleach like the anime
bleach i did on neopets i'm okay i did it i did it on gaya
online tomorrow no i've never i was a neopets girl anyway
the leader of wind clan was like tomorrow we shall i shall
get my oh they were he was doing a clad meeting i crashed
wind class clad meeting you're fucking wind queen what do
you mean you're crashing how did you even get there i
visited wind clan i don't even know how to leave this one
how do i leave the prayer for tomorrow you go to like the
clad and map and then you click join the map what you just
joined it no i didn't join the clan i just wanted visited
their camp go to camp oh i'm in river clan that's the wrong
place don't worry there's nothing fun happening now because
because i fucking crashed your clan i crashed your clan
meeting wait what about shadow clan what's shadow clan doing
oh you can drink water is is shadow clan still around shadow
clan yeah we've done away with those guys yeah a bunch of
everybody in shadow clan's dead There's nobody here.
There's nobody in Shadow Clan.
This looks like Thunder Clan reskin.
Bro, everybody in Shadow Clan is dead.
A fresh kill pile.
We gotta go kill somebody.
You gotta kill somebody?
I remember when I first, oh my god, there's a leader's dead.
When I first joined up the Warrior Cats RP server, and then
I got some, like, what was it, Queen?
some queen to feed me because I was like, wheeh.
Oh my, okay.
So can we like reload into a different server and just like
can I get a mother in roleplay?
I need that.
I need a mother figure.
They like picked me up and like was like when they picked me
up and was like fucking fucking feeding me and also trying
to take care of me.
Sold, sold, sold, sold.
Let's go join winclan we need a fucking fight uh actual we
need a finding they camp where the queen is where are the
queen definitely has to have like a like a queen i feel i
gotta change breed star then that's too much what is it
there's a loner here where are the other cats
where the are the other cats who are all the only win clan
is alive apparently I don't know who's who even wants wind
clan like what the hell even is that they weren't even
relevant in the story at any point right oh the clans wait
what about the kitty pets I'm gonna check if the kitty pets
are still around the kitty pets yeah I got ignored by the
kitty pets during my first time I'm going to win clan I'm
gonna go find a mom you're gonna find a mom
Wait, how do I go inside?
I don't know.
Where's the door in this house?
Oh, there's the door.
I don't know where, like, how do I open doors?
How the fuck do anybody do anything as a kitty pet?
It's just so peaceful.
Something about this feels wrong.
Like, these people are at such peace being little cats
sleeping away.
And I'm waiting for your awakening.
Like, ma'am, ma'am, ma'am.
chart chart oh wait me when i when i when i oh my god
there's a kitty pet right here oh you found the kitty i
found some kitty pets yes hello hello i'm lost i'm trying to
find my mommy oh my gosh i loaded right wait i loaded like
right in a bunch of them no wait a child
mommy is that you is this you no way a child wow no you
gotta be like ebc for mom like this person's just saying
censored things in fish emojis hello are you hungry for real
for real no way i don't know if i'm hungry
like no way stop bro this kitty fed is so mean what is he
doing he told me to starve i can't even tell what they're
saying horrendous things they told me the starve when what
are you what are the settings i don't know animations wait
animations maybe you can be people of i can't believe it i
can't believe this kitty fed i'm just trying to find a mama
i'm a baby hey i'm just a baby hey meow they're so mean i'm
just a little kid i haven't grown up this is why i'm gonna
be a bad boys because of my environment snuffy is it yeah i
feel like we're like unload kids at an adoption center yeah
yeah we're this is why i become a bad boy nobody nobody's
loved me yeah there you are oh my god what the are you doing
what the are you doing oh you know what happened to my name
wait what happened to my name my name was good oh you got
reported you got i got reported you got reported
I can't believe that you got reported Oh my god, you're
ruining this for children Wait, wait, this is a kid's I
don't, I'm not associating myself with you
I don't know her I don't know her I'm running away I'm not
Guys, we just loaded up the game being like, man, I want to
be just like Cropel.
He got so many bitches.
Yeah, but like, I didn't write that down.
I just, I'm going to be a bad boy.
I didn't say anything.
I just said I was thirsty because I wanted some mom to love
me.
I was thirsty for love.
I think you're going to get your account bad again.
I think your account's going to get bad.
Oh, I didn't do anything wrong.
I'll get it.
Why is this?
I read.
I've read your description.
What do you mean?
I literally...
Oh my god, there's like a bunch of loners.
You felt cold for a second.
Warm for another.
Then cold again.
You needed something to keep you anchor.
What, you snarred.
Everyone...
Oh, whoa!
Merry Christmas.
Snarf.
Oh my god.
We keep getting told to starve!
I keep...
This is my house.
Her stomach growled.
Wait, I gotta type this.
Wait, wait.
Okay, wait.
How do I fucking...
Dude, I picked up a toy.
I need to talk to everybody.
Doki Pelt looked around the barn.
She was still lost in it.
Trying to pick up a pack of cigarettes.
Trying to find her way.
She saw several cats in the, several cats in front of her,
her stomach growled.
Has anyone seen my mom?
Wait, not Doki Pelt, sorry.
Doki Kitt.
Yeah, yeah.
We're aging yourself up so early.
Doki Kitt, there we go.
Why did we all make, why didn't everybody choose their cat
to be Crow Pelt?
Like literally, they're all black cats.
blue eyes including myself sometimes because you guys all
want to be special i want to be realistic there's so many
cats in this house we belong to some crazy cat lady bro this
entire story is about being in a is written by four cat
ladies if you literally this is a cat lady literature genre
like Did anyone talk to me?
No, no, everybody's ignoring me because I'm a child.
Come watch TV in the house.
I hope they have Garfield on TV right now.
Minus one RP, stuffy.
You're not immersive.
Retta's on the couch as she flips.
through the channel's half hazard room.
We're in the house.
There's a TV and everything.
It's not bad RP.
This is we're literally indoor cats.
I'm indoor cat RP.
There's like a cat tower.
Oh my god, they're gonna pick me up.
Oh my god, they picked me up.
They asked my permission.
okay they asked my pushman i got picked up oh my god where
am i going is he gonna feed me is this my new mom too big do
i need to be extra small i don't need to be down size they
put me down i can't move i did something to my game held and
cradled okay how do i move feed me oh yeah did you got
picked up yeah i got picked you gotta be extra tiny oh my
gosh that's great i'm extra tiny right now i love how you're
like curled up so much a little pete hurt i know i'm so tiny
hurt are you are you hurt
wait sheave claws oh my god can i do animations can i like
sleep no you can't do anything back of the leg continues to
Doki continues to starve waiting for some cat to give her
food
I'm begging for food I'm need food guys where am I oh my god
these guys pick me up they're gonna pick me up and give me
food I think wait where are you I don't know No, I'm in the
barn.
No, I'm in the loner stuff.
The loner?
Oh, where's the...
It's the one with the kitty pup pup.
Where's the...
The loner.
What do you eat?
Doki Kit looks up to the cat that...
To the strange loner that picked her up anything.
I'm so hungry.
see i'm just trying to find a parental figure who will love
me but i think i'm getting like kidnapped i'm getting
abducted right now you're dragging me into the street plus
one rv i'm so immersive i'm hungry i'm pulling up my neopets
my neopets roleplay right now that's cabinet that's medicine
do you even flip and turn okay i'm gonna eat i'm gonna eat
my heart how do i how do i go to the loners i'm i'm eating
grass right now snuffy you eat grass i'm i ate my grass i
did it i it's good they made me eat grass hey like a horsey
there's like cat mint someone's like how am i so good at
this look i spent one more than one year warrior cats on
Neopets.
More than one year role playing?
Okay, I would do like high school role play, Neopets role
play, magical fantasy role play.
And then I would have like character sheets of like
templates of all these Neopets role play.
There's like a role play board in Neopets.
That's what I did on Gaia Online.
They would have like role play guilds and forums that you
could join.
And then there's like, there's like one where it was like
superheroes, cool roleplay.
I had so many.
Superheroes.
Yeah.
And then I remember one of them, one of my templates was
like a kid, like what a guy, a guy that knew like telepathy
or some shit.
I like telekinesis.
Oh yeah.
Telekinesis.
Oh my god.
I was on the roleplay leaderboard.
There's some good stuff then.
If you, if you're into that, then I have mini a world to
take you.
Do you want to try different?
Oh, Roblox world.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
Doki Kid signing out.
Doki Kid leaving.
That's all this time, right?
I got fed and I'm okay now.
Get fed, leaves.
Actual wild cat RP.
That really works.
I got fed, I leave now.
Goodbye.
that's all that matters
let's see let's see what's another good role play one um oh
my god where do i go there's one that like it's not as funny
and i genuinely but i genuinely have like a super good time
with it um i don't know if i can find it uh what is it
called i forget it's something it's something fantasy themed
it's really fun it's like those games where you like have to
survive like as a character like a animal and like other
animals can eat you and it's basically the role play but
like for serious though like that's the it was it was a code
you know oh man theory something with an e maybe let me see
if i can find it the one says the weather survival game is
like really good oh natural disaster that's super fun That
one's just a fun one.
Whether that weather.
Oh, it's natural survivor.
What's it about?
It's like we can play that one.
It's super fast and easy.
It's like, oh my god.
Probably one of the oldest classic Roblox games right there.
A natural disaster survival.
I can link you to if you don't see it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll just click on your link.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This one is super fun.
So instead of a curse game, this is a classic.
Survival.
Okay.
I'm waiting for this to pop up so I can join you.
Open my Roblox game client.
I hope the kids are okay.
I hope the kids.
This is all about how much the kids aren't okay.
This is like, trust your kids on where, if they know where
to go, during a natural...
What the hell?
Now we're back into regular Roblox territory.
You're best to survive the natural disaster.
If you die, you can spectate out of those.
are you in here yeah i think i'm in here wait what was maybe
maybe my room oh no no no no i think my room got full i'll
just join again and see if i've gotten to yours i don't know
where i am there's this cool guy oh my god look at him damn
it okay wait close the game i think we'll have to load up
together some giant chicken mug called bp is cool okay okay
okay i'm gonna load into it are you in my room no i think
yours is full this game is really popular oh really okay
okay how can i join with you though i don't see this is this
is the fun part of roblox's i don't really think you can too
much okay wait i'm just like yeah okay we'll on the count of
three let's like put it up together like one okay okay okay
i'm ready okay one two three okay boom let's see yeah let's
see we get loaded okay okay yeah yeah yeah maybe like we
should mute ourselves and then oh yeah yeah maybe that's
easier all right did you load in i'm loading it yeah i'm
ready okay i don't i don't see you dang it okay okay i see
san francisco there were no survivors okay okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna too i'll just say i'm not going to mute it there's
woody oh you guys are missing out you don't see woody yeah
okay i'm i'm opening it wait i need to show my chat woody
look at there's woody there's woody in roblox yeah how do
you get woody is this there's a fucking spider there's a
there's a woody in my roblox game oh my god there's a
fucking spider i've got like an i've got a spider woman i've
got spider woman there's an anime boy in my room what the
there's an anime boy okay wait let me okay i'm gonna mute my
i'm gonna mute myself so we can actually get in the game
together all right okay yeah yeah okay okay okay guys i'm
gonna mute myself guys we gotta make sure we get in a room
together give me give us a sec chat
okay We did it!
We did it!
Guys, it took us so many tries!
But there's fucking Lightning McQueen!
This was worth it.
Guys, this was worth it.
We have Lightning McQueen chat.
We have Lightning McQueen in our lobby.
Cachow.
Oh my god.
There he is.
Oh my god, I'm your biggest fan, Mr. McQueen.
Are they on a roadblock state?
Okay, okay, so here's what, here's, here's, here's natural
disasters.
Oh, we're in the Spanish lobby.
It's acid, it's acid rain.
It's acid rain.
Oh no, oh no, I'm going in.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Take shelter, take shelter.
This is a real simulation of a pandemic happening right now.
Oh my god.
A natural disaster.
Lady McQueen, he's got to get in the garage.
He knows how to play this game.
He's in the garage.
He has the experience.
Bro, we're in the Spanish servers.
We're in the Spanish servers.
Spanish?
Yeah, people are speaking Spanish.
Hello, Mr. McQueen.
I'm your biggest fan.
I'm your biggest fan, McQueen.
I mean, it's really, it actually is.
Wait, what?
Oh, my God.
past the servers so far that he's a Spanish server.
Oh, yeah.
Kuchow.
Is that the other house next door?
He said Kuchow.
It's Kuchow.
Kuchow with a man screaming fire emoji that's him.
That's Lady McQueen.
Is that actually the Spanish Wait, it's like a Chao in
Spanish?
Wait, it is?
Oh, my God.
It is Spanish.
Somebody else repeated him.
They were like, Chao.
Oh, my God.
Did we get here?
Did you live?
Yeah, okay.
So here's a hack.
If your health is still injured before the next game starts,
you got to do a hard read.
set or else you're at an unfair disadvantage and you're
missing each okay plastic roblox pack right here oh my god i
can't believe i can't believe i gotta figure out i gotta
figure out how to get this lightning mcqueen skin this is
fantastic this is a quake skin oh we shall this is your
fucking kura cosplayer what the hell we got fucking vtubers
in my instance i'm going I'm following Kuchow.
But I trust him.
I trust him.
I trust Spanish lighting McQueen.
This man is fucking spent money on this.
Okay, there's a bit of a cloud front coming in.
I don't know what the disaster could be.
Yeah, it looks like dense fog.
I'm on top of the ceiling to get a good purveying view of
the situation here.
Back to you, Doki.
I'm with Spanish lighting McQueen for an interview.
Oh, it's a fucking blizzard!
I'm in this.
Oh, no.
What do we do, Mr. McQueen?
You gotta run his engine.
Run his engine.
Okay, I got it.
Stay warm.
We warm.
Huddle together, guys.
Body heat, body heat.
Get body heat, body heat.
Get body heat.
Take off all your clothes and huddle up together.
Get inside McQueen for the heat.
We need the radiator.
What do you mean?
Do you think we're okay?
Mr. McQueen.
Cachow!
Oh my god.
Cachow.
Do you think we'll be okay guys?
I can't even see my HP.
wait my hp is cool my hp is so low oh you're half hp you're
half oh no the walls are turning into snow oh no don't touch
the snow oh no oh god look at smirk face ka-chow ka-chow
you're like i feel like we're a bunch of pokemon i know oh
my god he's a gamer look at his hp he's so high his hp is so
high oh god okay right i gotta wipe this is it how do you
win this game i mean you just have to survive that's how you
just get the highest points and survive as long as you can
oh that's how you do it surf central all right i'm pretty
sure i'm gonna die first before before you why didn't we get
put into the world wait what the hell yeah without us even
kachau didn't go oh my god we didn't we're just too good you
know we're just we're just we're just yeah he's not happy
spanish lady mcqueen is not happy about this look at him oh
god he's like where was my game where was my game oh oh
there's a weather machine to power up need a lift just 30
robux to get a green balloon what the fuck is the green
balloon oh my god i saw woody with a green balloon cheating
that's cheating it's like pay to win that's totally pay to
win that's one of the here classic avoid crowds wait does
that does that affect us sadly no no no because we're not
we're not we're not part of the like experiment down there
oh You can watch them, like, little ants, like, scramble.
Oh, my gosh!
McQueen is getting squished!
He's so popular.
He's getting squished!
Kuchow.
What did you do him?
Oh, my God!
He said it!
Wait, do your emote!
How do you do your emote?
Period.
Period, yeah.
It's period.
And then, here.
That's my emote.
Yeah.
Good job.
He's both shivering and warm.
I don't know what emotion this conveys.
Does someone just call him dad?
He really likes this girl.
He's like driving onto her.
Oh, no!
McQueen, stop!
Your career, McQueen!
McQueen, you can't be seen like this.
You have a wife.
You have a wife and your best friend!
It's a Portia!
Oh my god.
Why?
How could you do this in front of all of us?
Literally, you're our hero!
I think Spanish McQueen has like different standards.
Dude, we still- we still won!
That kind of does a win for us.
We're just gamers.
Did he just post an emote of an amoeba?
What the fuck is that emote?
what are you what is that evo
level four weather level four like one person down there my
classic are you gonna get on the rocket the rock there's a
rocket wait is this the only person playing the game wait
there's only we did it powered by oh there's four natural
disasters five natural disasters good shell wait wait wait
wait wait wait i think we need to go up i think we need to
go up there's yeah we need to leave the planet yeah we gotta
leave there's like five natural disasters somebody pay that
much to to have five natural disasters that's like we're
gonna die the rocket how did you get in the rocket you gotta
oh no did they did they knock down the the platform to cross
into it you gotta climb the no they knocked down the
platform to get into it a thing they Those monsters Hey,
Lum.
Are we dead?
Enable the rocket.
Volcanic eruption, fire, thunderstorm.
Oh my god, thunderstorm!
Guys, put on them!
Oh my god, you're a volcano?
I can't tell.
Oh, I'm so scared.
Oh, there's fire!
Are you in the rocket?
There's a tower.
It's a flash flood.
Oh, God.
That tower is getting destroyed by lava.
It's flood.
Oh, God.
I'm on the rocket.
No!
I'm dead.
No one's surviving that.
Oh, it's so fucked up.
Bro, no one's fucking surviving that.
Holy shit.
I like that you can just pay money to like instantly kill
people like nobody lived nobody thank you thank you uh cool
to x for like literally ending our life for like pay to end
pay to end forget pay to win that's a fun game mode yeah
this game is really addicting it's it's good fun it's just
art and it's just funny map and you know just silly Oh, no,
I think Lightning McQueen left.
No, no, he's at the bottom floor, contemplating life.
He's fighting with a dog.
Yeah, he's fighting with a dog right here.
With mentally unwell.
Mentally unwell?
Oh, okay, but having an ass in my name is available.
The Lightning is running away from the dog.
He's running away from his problems.
He's running away.
Just like the first movie, guys.
There were no survivors.
damn really no survivors i wonder why so fucked up i like
the volcano right next to the planet too all right snuffy
give us another server another server all right all right
let's find a new game that one's a good one a classic one
yeah the oldest game is like on roblox like i think that
thing is probably more than 10 years old i don't know if
there's a way to like look when it got posted or something
but yeah that thing is That is a relic.
Created March 28th, 2008.
Holy, the person, this stickmaster Luke has made so much
money.
Oh, yeah.
That is, that was a big one.
No, you know, the biggest brain, oh my God.
You make your own Roblox world and then make your own Roblox
world and then ironically put cosmetics in there so people.
will have to spend robux you can hire somebody like like a
game dev in roblox to make a game for you and then you can
just like get rich from microtransactions oh yeah we're
gonna farm children that's so ethically right the target
section the target children's choice section is just riddled
with like off-brand roblox games that like roblox creators
got like money from their game and then they just want to
make that same game as like a standalone and just keep
getting money from like the big one is it's called like pet
simulator or something right now oh wait i've seen that
before yeah yep yep it's crazy there's so much drama
regarding it too it's insane um okay so i think another good
one hmm what are you feeling we can we do another role play
we can do kind of a never before seen experience let's try
to never before seen experience let's like try all different
experiences here yeah yeah get the full roblox roblox style
okay let me let me let me let me peruse what i've got saved
here so far i'm gonna change my face oh my god oh this might
be an interesting one i've never been to this one but it is
a it is a official sponsor one oh what's it called oh wait
we shouldn't say it so then we could actually i linked you
yeah yeah i don't say we should you can let me know it was
like something you'd want you'd want to oh wait yes yes yeah
yeah i'm opening i'm opening it
oh my gosh yes i've never done this one so i'll be new to it
as well oh my god it's a fucking tycoon it's one of those oh
my god oh my god it's so cute would you like a quick
walkthrough Sure.
Oh my god.
Wait, I'm gonna join you first.
Let me know when you're in the server.
I'm in, I'm in.
Okay, I'm gonna, are you sure you want to leave the
experience?
Yes, sadly.
Sadly, I have to.
One of my other favorite, like, official sponsors is in,
like, one of the roleplay town worlds is, like, a canonical,
like, Home Depot.
Like, a real sponsor for Home Depot.
Home Depot has a fucking Roblox server?
Yeah, they have, like, in one of the roleplay towns, they
have, like, an official, like, like building where you can
load in and like have like sponsored people got to my god
also you have to rejoin the server because i think they got
snagged i don't this one might be a single player game it's
a single player it could be it could be some of them are
some of them are i don't know no how can okay i loaded into
another one house will you join my tycoon oh i think it is
this server does not this experience is not support private
servers Alright guys, I'll show you what it looks like And
then we're gonna find another server Chat, I'll show you
what we joined I'm pretty sure you saw it from Snuffy's side
But like No, I didn't show it I didn't show it Guys, look
Look, it's the Hello Kitty experience Look at that There's
Sonomoro Hi, it's a pleasure Welcome, hello Kitty Oh my god
Look at this Look at this There's got... Of course, there's
fucking gotcha.
How crazy is gotcha?
Sonomoro!
Where's Sonomoro?
I don't want to do all of this.
I just want to talk to Sonomoro.
Alright, I'm done.
I've had my experience.
It's like that Hello Kitty.
What's that Hello Kitty game that self-park advertised?
Hello Kitty Adventures?
Is that it?
Oh, Hello Kitty Island Adventures?
Yes!
It's basically like the free version of Hello Kitty Island
Adventures.
It's actually, it's still a free game.
I have it on my iPhone.
If you have, like, an iPod, Apple device, it's free on the
Apple Arcade.
Oh, whoa.
I'm not sponsored, by the way.
But if Hello Kitty Island Adventure would like to sponsor
me, I'm right here.
Absolutely.
It's very cute.
Right here.
I've never played this one.
I linked you a new one.
I never played it, but it looks appetizing.
It looks very entertaining.
I'm going to join off of you.
Give me a sec.
I'm going to leave.
I can't believe Hello Kitty Island Adventure didn't win one
game of the year.
They got so fucking robbed.
I know.
I was so sad.
That should have been best mobile game.
What the fuck is this?
Let's try to find foods hiding in the house.
This is us.
I'm not even in your server.
What the fuck?
What are we?
Are we?
What the fuck is this?
Okay.
What are we trying to do?
I think it said you have to hide or something.
Or find food?
I don't...
I don't see like an enemy anywhere.
Wait, speed fast.
Yeah, we see enemy.
Wee!
Oh my god, they're so tiny!
Hi!
it is so tiny i fell down there's a chef but where's the
chef a chef yeah apparently there's a chef somewhere i can't
get out i can't get out i'm scared yeah i'm gonna like hide
under i'm gonna be like a food that you dropped and that you
haven't like seen under the fridge oh that's true me too i'm
under the i'm under the chair i'm under the chair there's no
way they'll find me i'm going to the fridge oh apparently
he's gonna a spawn or something oh yeah so it's like it's
like it's like prop on oh i'm not big enough to go under the
pizza wait how do you change how do you change i don't know
but wait i can be pizza i found a pizza i'm here now i'm
pizza wait pizza i found a pizza okay these are really good
There's a strawberry!
Oh my god, I'm bread.
Oh my god, bread is so...
Get over here.
I'm gonna be under... There's no way people are gonna find
me.
Guys, if we're all in the fucking same place, the chef's
gonna know we're not we're...
I belong here.
This is... I belong...
I belong here too.
Wait, wait, wait.
Let me get on top.
Let me get on.
Let me stack up.
This is a cursed sandwich.
wait yeah you lie down lie down okay okay wait let me move
up there's no way they'll know we're pizza why is that guy
named urinary there we go it's perfect they'll never know
guys and there's 20 apples under here it's gonna look weird
there's 20 apples down here maybe maybe it'll buy us time
they'll they'll reach for all the apples and we're in the
very far back we're hiding oh my god there's a chris where
the fuck's the chef like yeah why is it not a what am i
what's the what's the game plan we just did he die is this
it hide and seek he is too small what does that mean he is
too small where's the chef how are we supposed to get found
and there's nothing to find maybe maybe it's just around is
there like a timer somewhere I feel like we've been like
walking around for a while when you go fast Give me over.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so fucking slow.
My legs can't fucking handle this dumpy
I'm fine.
Oh, I found the pizza under the couch.
Yeah, yeah, that was me I am so fucking slow.
Where's the chef?
Who are we hiding from?
I'm just gonna there's like so so many things here it's just
there's a me oh there's a whole other room maybe yeah
there's a room are we trying to find the fucking chef is
that what's happening i don't want to find it myself yeah
this boy i find the chef who's crumpet where's your face
crumping oh my god sweetie bye there's a bugget what is this
i'm in the bathroom soon How'd you guys get up there in the
back?
Oh wait, is it just us finding other hidden items?
Is this the game?
That's the game is just finding the food.
That's just finding the food But it's adorable.
I kind of love it.
Me too late.
No, we clicked it.
It just says I'm too small.
I'm too small.
How did you even get up?
there wait what's this there's a book there's a fucking
croissant I'm gonna be a croissant is this guy he's
literally like an and I'm croissant man now there's like a
tiny piece somewhere too I think that is the game you just
fucking you're just finding all the item what what croissant
this guy's like a singular blueberry he's so fucking tiny oh
my god yet crumpet is it the crumpet guy yeah he's so
fucking tiny it was just the name oh my god there's a giant
melon up here oh wait i'm like weighing this down it's like
an elevator system this is worse waldo but food guys guys i
need there's a tomato oh my god there's several tomatoes but
i want to be the giant melon oh guys i need to be the giant
melon addicted to this like i'm i can do this i'm helping
this i no i'm trying to that me and my me and this tomato
gang are trying to walk up the fucking vacuum guys to lift
him up on this elevator and i thought he was gonna climb to
new heights but all he did was just like jump off oh my god
how did this tomato do it yes let me climb all right wait no
i'm too fucking lying i can't do this as a croissant i'm
gonna do as an orange
guys i need to be the giant watermelon we're all trying to
fucking food like and they're just like sitting on each
other and i'm like is this the equivalent of like role play
like like food role play is like is this i'm getting on Joe
is so pointless.
Oh, here we go.
How did that other tomato do it?
Oh, there's a banana.
I see a banana up here.
I'm playing getting over it, but that's fruits.
This is a hockey arena.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I can't stop.
I can't stop sitting.
How do we get up here, guys?
Guys.
No, no!
Oh, I knocked somebody off.
Get out, get out, get out.
I need to get up there and be a melon.
come on this is it it looks so much better to be a circular
fruit I give up I can't turn into a melon of giving up how
do you find the melons it's like literally up there it's up
top there all the way up here it's all the way up there you
gotta get up through the dives in vacuum I couldn't get up
there I did but then we have to build a fucking ladder
together to get up there.
I'm a piece of pizza.
I'm gonna be a vital, I'll be a vital... We need a ladder.
We need a make a ramp, dragons!
Make a ramp!
Why the fuck did you jump?
Why?
Did you die?
I guess you'll die!
Build a ladder!
I need that melon!
Excuse me.
fill the ladder so that's the end game to be a melon we need
some congestion oh god somebody lie down oh shit it's just a
it's just a there's an egg here we're all trying to see the
tomato we're all trying to climb with single file guys
single file no what a long ass line are we in the fucking uk
in the queue right now we're at disneyland there's no fast
pass here no we gotta get a fast pass i gotta get my app out
and yeah i feel like we're there's no fast look at it oh my
god there's a traffic jam of all these fruits guys get up i
need my melon the fucking tomato is too good i don't
understand I can't fit.
Alright, here you go.
Get up.
A cookie.
Oh my god, a cookie?
Guys, I don't think the tomatoes, we need like something
flat and then you lie down and then you stack up amongst
each other.
Become a pizza.
Yeah, yeah.
All pizzas.
Pizzas and breads.
Change all the pizzas and breads.
That's the meta, dude.
All pizza meta.
Yeah, yeah.
All pizza and bread.
Change now.
Change yourself now.
Oh, I found a mango.
I got knocked into a fucking mango.
Oh my god, look at them!
They've stacked up!
We're all doing it!
We've actually coordinated it.
Yeah, but I think one guy, like, killed the other.
This guy's like a Calzone.
He's a whole pie.
Oh my god, this is it!
Oh!
What?
Wait!
Wait, this is it!
Guys, collide into each other and then push me up!
Guys, we collide into each other and then we ragged all into
it.
Pump, bump, collide right down!
force force myself to rag doll up there
oh my god somebody fucking got launched up look at the
people trying to make a ladder up top snuffing you see that
it's actually so useful though like their brain is huge here
i come i'm gonna go test it out for myself okay taking a
nice walk can't get collided my god they've made like a
whole okay don't walk up there don't jump don't jump at all
okay never mind ignore my strat of the colliding it doesn't
work anymore just don't no some we just need one person to
beat a melon this is like this is like that one meme where
from the jimmy neutron where it's like the pizza is
aggressive just flying everywhere oh my god i just saw pizza
oh my god oh my god do you see the fucking apple stacking up
against each other hello i'm sorry i didn't i seem to wear
look at the stack look at this i can't move are you stuck
wait you're stuck i'm stuck please help mr tomato i think
you gotta swap i think you gotta swap characters what no no
please guys please let me
going back up i'm back down okay i got stuck but i'm good
i'm coming back all right we're single file guys stop guys
let me get up this is what do they call these things like a
immovable force we can't progress i want to join i want to
join them up there look at them wait some of them fucking
fell what happened oh wrong direction where did i go what
the fuck where the fuck did i go i need to be bigger and
better assert my dominance over the ladder i hear you just
getting pushed around like a nobody i got like pushed out of
bounds i'm here i'm here maybe guys this is it'll launch me
guys i think i'm gonna give up guys I don't think we're
getting to that melon.
Guys, I don't think we're getting to that melon.
Let me through.
I'm important.
I'm an orange.
Oh my god, there's an Onigiri on the table.
How cute.
Guys.
I haven't seen anybody with that one.
I haven't been up here in so long.
Find their tissue next to the Onigiri.
Oh my god, we made it.
We made it, Yozo.
You and I We did it Alright Did you get up there?
You a melon?
No, not really We're trying to figure out how to get up top
I'm gonna try and push Oh my god Oh my god the lemon Oh he
kicked out the other apple The other apple got kicked out
Okay I'm ragged Okay I shouldn't ragged off Wait someone got
to the melon Oh my god they did it Oh my god they did it
They're a
melon!
Click it!
He's literally standing there, just haunting you.
Click the melon!
I want to see what it looks like!
Did he click it?
I got fucking squashed.
That's not a melon.
That's a pumpkin.
Where the fuck is the melon?
Did he not even click it?
Where the fuck is that melon?
He wants you to have the satisfaction yourself.
of being the first melanin of the map.
Get me out of this game!
Just click the melanin!
Just click it.
I just want to know what it looks like.
Oh!
Look at him!
He's so big!
He did it!
Oh my god!
Look at him!
It was worth it.
Look at this giant melon.
Look at him.
Worth is giving me like a sense of disassociation.
as I get, like, shoved to the floor and, like, it's hurt.
And I'm just like, who am I?
Let's, like, kick the melon.
Kill the melon.
We're all just, like, make this guy's a pumpkin.
Huge melons.
Oh, my God.
We killed the melon.
We actually killed the melon.
Good job, guys.
Good job.
We did it.
Let's find another game, Snuffy.
Alright, Snuffy, game ever this is the best game ever oh my
goodness the best server okay okay okay no pressure no
pressure no pressure that's a lot of pressure or anything no
pressure or anything stuffy oh goodness oh goodness goodness
okay okay okay okay okay hold on i need to i need to cook
for
Wait, did I start the game for real?
Did I start the game?
Oh my god!
I've been, wait, what?
Found hiders?
Oh, I finished the game.
Wait, what?
That was, there was really a game the whole time?
It was, it was trying to find the food.
That's it.
I literally restarted the server.
You were like the server owner?
What?
I'm in a different server now, I think.
I think I'm in a different server.
Yeah.
This was the game.
It's just, you gotta find all the food.
That was it.
Wee.
I found the melon and I won the game.
I thought that was just all about, like, teamwork.
It was literally finding all the food and then that's it.
And then you could end the game.
I found four and then the game was like good enough It was
like you found four good for you I found one that's like
Roblox Omegle Is that what it was called?
Omegle?
Oh I found This is tomato?
Oh my god Or is it I'm me now Okay we should not play Roblox
Omega just for the sake of our safety we should not yeah
yeah yeah it's like a heart in the game that's like that's
we do not play roblox omega i i don't think i feel safe
playing roblox omega just saying my only favorites is nikki
minaj's gag city that's not a very good one what what even
is that it's nikki minaj's gag city that doesn't
oh my god okay okay okay the ultimate this is a tough one
there's a lot of different options here okay how about what
what is what does chat think is their most favorite roblox
game yeah yeah chat what is like the ultimate game i've got
a lot of niche games but they're all good but i wouldn't
never say any of those are the best the best so what's this
starscape what's starscape i have not heard of that one so
clearly that's a lie There's a lot of Starscape.
Starscape?
Yeah, it's Star and Escape.
Never heard of this.
The Mimic.
Isn't that the...
Isn't that like...
Wait, isn't that...
Wait, isn't that... That's famous, right?
Isn't that famous Roblox game?
The Mimic?
I don't know.
Sounds familiar.
It does sound familiar.
Good girl sorority What is a wild horse island Wait someone
says mimic try the mimic Alright Should we do it I can let
me let's see it Let me let me let me take a Let's see what
it is It is highly rated It seems very popular Alright let's
try it I think it's a horror game It's fine It's robo How
scary can roblox be Like That's like the doors This is a
pretty spooky game How scary can Roblox horror be, Snuffy?
Come on.
Okay.
Right.
This looks pretty high-deaf.
No.
Whoa.
How scary can this be?
Am I already in the...
Where are you?
Um...
I'm in the lobby.
I think I see you.
See me?
It took my skin.
I took my skin away.
It did, too.
Wait, where are you?
Oh, you're just like a regular woman now.
Yeah, no.
Guys, guys, look at Snowman.
Look how you don't even have a shirt.
You're fucking naked.
What the fuck?
You have pants on.
I can't even tell.
Yeah, like a Garfield.
I was going to say Darfield.
Dokey Garfield.
Oh, yeah, my Garfield face.
There's saves.
Okay, so over here, there's invite friends.
Invite friends.
Is that like...
Isn't it this one?
Oh, that's like invite, invite real friends.
Okay, yeah.
Lobbies.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lobbies, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Might put us into another different instance.
That...
No, no.
Wait, what?
Okay, I can invite you.
I think let me let me like hide the game really.
Yeah, me too.
Let me hide the game.
I don't know what happened, but I did.
Oh, it says I joined you.
Did you get my invite?
Did I like look through it.
Look at your actual Roblox like notifications or something.
Wait, I have a Roblox notification.
It's like on the website, on the website, maybe.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I see it.
Invite.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, joy.
Open.
I was like Can't notification No way you're talking about
Okay Play My end I don't know I think I'm back in the lobby
Oh me too Me too Wait how the fuck do we start Guys how do
we start this game Back in the lobby Let's see We just start
Play Just play Oh Oh there's lobbies If you play Yeah do we
chapter one chapter one josey wait lobby there's like four
fucking books is this japan oh my god normal multiplayer
dude oh there you go i joined you that's me hey i just
started before you might that's right there was no like
private lobby oh okay a butterfly a beautiful butterfly How
scary can a Roblox lobby be?
Whoa, I've joined Fart.
Flashing lights and jump scares.
Uh-oh.
Oh my god, it's dark.
There's jump scares, guys.
Look, Quinta Aztecs?
Quinta?
Look, Quinta Aztecs.
Do we just go inside?
We are at a school.
Whoa, I feel like I'm drunk.
I've got, like, a wobbly camera.
Whoa.
How do we...
Where are you?
You get in?
I'm right behind you.
You see me?
Yeah, I see you.
But like, where do we go?
We are drunk.
What the fuck is this?
It's like wobbling.
That was a crazy fucking party, man.
Oh my god, that was fucking crazy.
Let's go back to school.
Let's go back to school property.
Oh my god, we're gonna break in.
Let's break in a school.
Mr. Henderson's never gonna expect this.
I think we took his beer out of his car.
Oh my god.
Bro, bro, we gotta go in Mr. Henderson's class.
And yet bro steal steal.
We gotta love bro.
He's gonna freak out if we rearrange all the chairs bro
Rearrange the chairs.
What are they gonna look like just like they're gonna look
so disorderly Yeah, we're gonna be like this is in my chair.
Oh my god, bro We gotta move the desk like just one
centimeter like up or something and then people are gonna be
like whoa That's weird.
This doesn't feel oh my god.
There's stamina.
There's the door seems to match this door seems lap too
maybe i can't prank our senior prank man we're doing our
fucking senior prank right now bro oh this is the key man i
think i think this is the door over here is that the door
bro oh yeah bro bro is this it oh bro we're gonna he's not
gonna expect this principal wall is gonna get so mad bro
this kid opens backpack he need oh my god oh my god
principal waller's not why are the toilets just like out of
the open no way bro is this how boys live their life is
there just like toilets like with no doors yeah i mean when
they pee with the urinals you don't need doors it doesn't
even look like a urinal that's like a straight up toy toy
look it's look there's budget cuts this is not a very good
school bro this is a big boy's lock oh my god you look like
this particle like your fucking head looks like looks like
the fucking monster bro bro bro i got to the gym bro oh my
god oh my god we gotta i need to get to the other side wait
why is there grass in the yeah why is there what the what's
wrong with this gym also why did i forgot to bring my
glasses or something like why is it blurry in front of me i
got that depth of field eye around me yeah bro i forgot to
bring my glasses man this is embarrassing key is needed yeah
i find the key bro bro i don't like the sound of my
footsteps here i'm not as hell dude i got pink boots yeah
bro i think there's mold i think budget cuts hit hard man
yeah this is looking i mean i kind of like this like nature
look to it maybe you know like that's kind of like oh oh you
get the key no but i found the pool man that's ominous don't
drown do you know how to swim oh i do but i felt swimming
class i felt failed my swimming lessons like three times in
a row because i couldn't do the frog the frog was it the
frog and the butterfly i don't know Is the frog and the
butterfly the same thing?
But I fell to, like, three times in a row.
And then my parents gave up.
I see it.
Oh, are you swimming?
They're like, okay, I guess you'll frog.
They didn't want to...
They didn't want to keep, like, Oh, my God, this kid plays
Valorant.
Bro.
I like this cat.
Oh, my God.
That's crow feather.
I can't really shape.
What does it say?
cherry blossoms a bloom upon the arrival of the something
new i know that character that's women the arrival of the
woman time something blue average high school it smells in
here no wonder this is a horror game it would smell in here
there's a sova oh my god there's like trash bags all right
we gotta go back why do they have a computer room right next
to the pool bro this guys a freak man where the fuck is the
key there's another door over here in this shed oh is using
the keys in the shed what happened in the shed oh oh there's
the key from the key now i can open the gym door does it not
go in my oh it just stays there for jesus every time i look
at your face game about you you look so fucking smug like
every time i look at your face this giant cat person beside
me oh apparently we have to find a cherry blossom key this
is not the right one oh the tree this is a this is a gym so
it should be all right here you go we gotta go to the gym
now can we die in this game i assume we can I think we can
probably this looks like we would be at risk of like death
yeah yeah I think it should be how this is how we die my
feet scared me on the other side don't worry the witch can't
show up now we're still in the beginning oh we have infinite
lives so it doesn't matter it's here how do you know because
I Oh, there's the cherry blossom key.
A tree.
Oh, maybe we start the monster at the cherry blossom.
It started cold drinks.
Alright.
Let's go.
Oh, that's her.
How does Sakura tree grow in the middle of nowhere?
That's freaky.
How did it?
Now, this is me at 3 a.m.
This is you at 3 a.m.
What the fuck are you doing?
You fringed.
all right open the door okay she likes to mimic them be
cautious don't let yourself be deceived turn back now before
it's too late leon who the fuck is leon leon help what are
you doing this isn't resident evil 4.
wait what is she likes to mimic them do not let yourself be
i hate this i mean people that's oh my god what the fuck
that was a blow dryer that's that's scared of it out of me
okay we maybe we should have like a code to like reassure if
this is like you and me bro they have gucci bags oh is this
what gucci is yeah that's gucci oh my god they have gucci in
sanrio is this what gucci is did you see that oh i just like
static in my ears i thought my like just malfunction that
was terrible what the fuck what did you see did you see
something yeah i saw something i think i made fun of this
man's gucci bag and he got mad yeah he got some real real
school experience oh i don't like that oh don't keep behind
us oh oh oh she mad she angry nobody's perfect that's why
pencils have erasers she's gone you showed her your key and
she left i showed you my key please respond i'm gonna insert
this somewhere where was a locked door this one wait so do
you actually have hearing aids oh i'm good i've got good
hearing okay i'm gonna say what the did you do no it just
sounded like static oh there's a hole in me what's this hole
hey if you're reading this I don't know how much longer you
have left before you come into contact with her.
Be careful out there.
And whatever you do, don't go into the basement.
The keys are in the room across this one.
Please just throw it out.
I couldn't do it myself.
The key wasn't normal.
It's cursed.
If you choose to go in there, no promises, you'll be making
it back.
All right, let's go in there.
I picked up a couple keys.
They gotta be a little bit more like descriptive.
I picked up key number two.
Oh, how the fuck did we get here?
Whoa.
Okay, I can really use those glasses.
I need these glasses, man.
Why is there a fucking pool with trees under here?
Oh, yeah.
I feel like I feel like I'm gonna get... Wait, what the fuck
is that?
Oh, God, I got goosebumps.
What the fuck is that?
Do you see that?
I... Do you see that?
I... It's a... It's the woman!
Is that the woman?
It's the woman.
What are you doing here?
It's not real, isn't it?
Especially not in the game.
Women are real?
What are you doing here?
Nonprotection.
What happened?
Are you okay?
I don't think she liked that, dude.
I called her out on her fucking gamer blog.
all right opening that door thank you we got this permacini
are we in japan now no we're in no this is not japan this is
this looks like one of them silly games this is not japan
these are not japanese characters unless they unless they're
kanji oh no we're in japan that's not kanji okay yeah oh my
god They took us to Japan.
There's two bookstores next to each other.
My mom was okay with this, dude.
I didn't sign a...
Oh my god, did you sign, like, the permission form from your
mom?
I don't...
I forged it.
You forged your signature?
Bro!
That's not cool.
There's three bookstores back to back.
This is not a very, like, smart business decision.
It is a school trip.
Maybe you were in, like, a library section.
Oh, hey, there's another...
okay that was so cheap that was such a cheap jump yeah that
was like a 2009 like i just opened a youtube video we got
like fanap man driving down the street bro that was so cheap
man where are you if that's not yeah fuck you man
god all right next door next door apparently we die in this
next part oh yeah yeah the key to the hidden door is this
like run for your life kind of moment maybe this is the maze
yeah yeah wait i hear people i think we're gonna die stuffy
i think i think we're gonna die stuffy just stay to the
right just stay to the right you know that's the main strat
right stay to the
I don't hear her anymore yet.
I don't like this, Snuffy.
I don't feel so good.
I don't... I think she's around the corner.
What's a big maze?
What the...
Snuffy, maybe Roblox games can be scary.
Oh yeah, yeah, you're feeling the stress?
Uh-oh.
Oh my god, I just I just see you fucking just fall You just
you just you just She just like touches you and then you
fucking just fell It was literally like a tall woman
standing emoji just like she just stood there And I saw a
woman and died Oh my god
Okay, one more time, one more time.
Let me see if I can get through this.
Let's see.
I don't think that was right.
I think that was a dead end.
I think so, too.
All right.
We can do this together as a team.
Here, here, here, here, here.
Wait, what do you think?
Oh, wait, what's this?
Here, it has to be here.
There's, like, stuff here.
It's a dead man.
There's a key.
Yeah, I got the key.
Key two.
Okay, key two.
I got key three.
No, it's called, what is key three?
Key three.
Oh, key three.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, but where's the door?
I didn't see a door.
wait how do we hide from her like what's the mechanic i
don't know well okay she has to go to one of us and then
whoever lives run past her this is the strat oh my god i'm
so scared oh here you go we have to look for the doors okay
let's go okay okay all right door the door at i wonder if
it's the same area always oh the last one oh yeah yeah so
it's like i know this game like the back of my hand oh bro
what the fuck there's so many games why wait where did you
go where did you go i'm not scared i'm scared too i'm dead
i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead i'm
dead i'm dead i don't know i don't know where you are i'm
dead i'm dead i'm i'm coming i'm coming i'm coming where are
you where are you snuffy i'm dead oh oh no where am i i'm in
several dead ends we split up what happened to teamwork i'm
coming i'm going i'm not coming i'm not coming anymore i'm
not coming oh my god oh my god oh my god okay okay you can't
run you can't run from her you can you can you can you can
you can you can you can you can you can you can the door
anywhere i'm back in the beginning i'm back in the beginning
i'm back in the beginning i'm back in no no no no i can just
run out i found it oh my god i found it though you found it
yeah yeah yeah where is it if you go over can i just die and
come to you i think so is it to the right or to the left it
was to the left it's to like in the middle almost you did it
oh nice Just one of us has to find it.
We did it.
Yay!
I contributed.
Look, I found the key.
You found the door.
Yeah, yeah.
She chased me.
That was fucking scary.
She literally, the funniest thing is, like, she doesn't do
anything.
She just, like, stands, like, standing.
You have, like, your Discord.
You have, like, a Discord, like, a stabilizer thing or
something.
So when you start screaming, it was just static because it
was so loud.
Let me check my Discord settings.
Oh my god.
I was just like, what the fuck?
Sorry.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, wait.
You start playing music.
Oh, I have echo cancellation.
Oh yeah, noise suppression.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Noise suppression.
I have all this shit.
Oh my god, no.
It is so funny.
I'm so fucking sorry.
Oh my god, my discord audio is probably so terrible.
Discord shakes first generally.
okay there she is you first milady what i just i did the
last one you go ahead you go ahead fine fine i'm gonna go to
the left there's no way oh my god okay
i didn't give her eye contact see she didn't hurt me because
i didn't look it was just text jump scared yeah it's just
text okay where do we go talk to the farmer farmer where
would the farmer be where's the farmer's daughter whoa we
gotta walk and dead this inventory but there ain't no
inventory I haven't picked up anything but keys dude we're
gonna walk and dead this farmer walk and dead this farmer
yeah let's eat his legs oh I found him wait where are you I
haven't seen you around before oh there's the farmer we're
not from here it says click to continue Oh, well, please be
careful around here.
My brother recently went into the city and he hasn't been
back since.
I don't know how much longer I'll be able to stay here.
She's probably already watching us as I speak.
If you've seen a lady playing the Bihu, it's already too
late.
We did.
I did see that lady.
We saw that lady together.
Can I?
Yeah.
How about I live here and bring her here with you?
I guess we go straight, right?
I guess so.
Why are we being haunted?
Because we picked up a key.
Explore the cave.
Search for the door.
guess that's because like bro i just wanted to do my senior
prank man senior prank now now we've got now we travel to
japan accidentally showed up into the cursed lands of the
japanese farmhouses oh i don't like this i think these are
the weeping angels is that like a doctor who thing yeah i
think that's the like you have to have eye contact or them
or they're gonna start fucking coming over to us i don't
know are you a doctor you fan um i watched doctor oh they
are they are they are they are i fucking knew it i fucking
knew it
what was that oh my god another dead person is this the
brother no it's a woman i knew it i knew it was weeping
angel there was no other explanation why they were stones
Oh, oh, there's more of them.
Oh my god, there's more of them.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, I'm echoing in your, in your, in your mic.
Oh, are you?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, Oh no no no no no True
Oh God Oh God my stamina Am I going backwards?
Oh god I don't know I'm going forwards Whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa Uh Okay I don't know
where I am I don't remember which way I was going Oh don't
worry one of one of us has to make it If I die you're gonna
have to figure it out though I do it Oh I think it was this
way I think I'm going the wrong way I think it was this way
I think it was this way I'm gonna go this way Oh Oh Oh
There's the crazy lady Oh Every time I look at her I get
goosebumps I'm in the house Nafi The original one Or the new
one I don't know New house New house I don't even I'm in I'm
in the The crumbling New house Oh Looks like Down is the
only place to go.
I can go left.
Don't worry, Snuffy.
I'm gonna beat this game for us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I didn't.
Oh, I thought I died.
Oh, thank God.
We're in the hotel.
From Japan to a hotel?
We're getting a tour of the city, a beautiful garden, and
now we get a full expense-paid trip to a hotel.
Oh, my God.
I hate this game.
who's this what's who's chat with chat with hamburger who
the fuck is hamburger bro she has a club penguin shirt this
is all her doing man who is she oh you go what is she doing
japanese myth i have heard about i don't recall much about
it but i do know she can bring you anywhere she pleases
eventually those targeted by her fall into madness are you
into madness you're like a penguin flapping on the floor
there's like a club penguin fan hamburger cheese is this
like a real person or is this i feel so maybe it's like a
make a wish her make a wish is to i mean okay is it up
because like she's in a wheelchair and i was like maybe her
make a wish is to be in a roblox game like is that is that
fucked up for me to say like
like why is there like hamburger why is there a freaking
hamburger cheese i mean i think that like maybe it's
somebody in the lobby or something it just like picks a
player that was like in but she's in that wheelchair where
are you wait i i can't stand my presence is my presence is
being hunted wait what is that you over there was that you
oh she's on me she's on me now Did you die?
No, no, she just kind of stopped coming for me.
Oh my god, dude, I hear her or she's she's fucking Fucking
playing that fucking guitar right now behind me Strumming on
that guitar
Thank you for the elevator music Where are you?
Where did you I don't know what to do.
She's like impossible to avoid
Wait, she's actually only capable of moving in a singular
direction Bro, where the fuck are you?
I'm about to win us a game I hate this bro whoever suggested
this like a gay fuck you man But you didn't come with me to
the next floor I did.
I was already in the next floor.
I got I got there before you got there.
Oh, I thought you died I thought that's why you screamed.
What are there's a oh my god.
There's a map take a look I hate this game.
I hate this game.
Okay, so simply, okay, so Brothers, I fucking hate this
these cheap jumpscares.
Take a left take a left, take a left take a left take a take
a how do you know where to go okay i look there's a map
right here you just gotta memorize it okay there's a map
okay okay you're gonna figure this out for me because i
don't know take a left take another left take a right all
right i'm at it i'm i'm walking i don't know i i'm walking
okay oh i see you i'm right behind you.
You're right behind me?
Yeah.
There's a monster right in front of me, so we gotta fucking
figure out how to do this together.
Oh, there you are.
Okay, there's the girl right in front of us.
Okay, let's split up.
One of us has to figure out.
Okay, I'll go right.
Let's split up, gang.
Okay, skip it.
Truly one of us can't find it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
She'll be dividing our attention, so one of us will die, one
of us will succeed.
Oh, that's me!
That's me!
Goodbye!
I'm just...
Oh, there is a map.
What the fuck?
It's pretty big.
Okay.
Front.
Guys, memorize this map right now for me.
Okay.
Front, forward, left, forward, left, forward.
Right?
Okay.
Wow, that was awful.
That was really awful.
That was so bad.
Oh, my god.
That's you.
Okay, okay, let's figure this out together.
Did you look at the map?
Oh, yeah.
Let me look at the refresher.
Okay, okay.
Let's look at the refresher.
Okay.
FL, FLR.
F-L-F-L-F-L.
F-L-L-R.
Wait.
F-L-R-F.
Okay.
Alright guys type in like FLRs type in FLRs guys type in
First direction FL Yeah, yeah, yeah LR R Right Guys, I don't
know.
I think we already fucked it up.
I think we already fucked it up guys I feel like Guys, oh
no, and then F here F here, right?
F I trust you and then what?
F right?
L?
I like L.
And then F?
We skipped it?
F?
No.
Or was it R?
I'm going R.
One of us has to...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This always works in the movies.
Yeah, and then I'll go F.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
And then I'm gonna go L.
This is...
And then...
Should I go R?
I don't know.
I'll go R if you go F.
i'll go i'll go r r and then l i'm going f all right that is
a that is a dead this is exactly where i died i think i
think this is where i died last time okay i'm going f okay i
definitely went the wrong way i she's on me she's on me oh
my god it's the guitar drummer
the ceiling climber.
I got the guitar strummer.
She's got the ceiling climber.
I got the guitar.
There's two of them?
Oh, no.
Where do we?
It's over.
It's so over.
I literally hear you running from her.
I'm so lost.
I'm so lost, guys.
Whoa!
Wait, you did it!
Oh my god, we did it!
I knew splitting up was the right idea.
Yeah, I'm so...
We distracted them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're in my now.
Divide and conquer.
Just like my favorite war politician said.
Whoa.
End of chapter one.
We did it.
I think this is...
I think it's a good time to call it because I...
Yeah, yeah.
I can beat the game.
And we beat the game, guys!
Guys, we beat the game!
Oh my god, we're gamers!
Where's the key?
Back to the lobby, let's go.
Yeah, get me out of here.
Roblox core games, man.
They need something else.
Oh my god.
We beat the game!
I never trust the recommendations on these.
They be jump scare city.
Oh my god.
Beat the game, the mimic.
Another easy win.
Oh my god.
GG's.
Next time I'm taking us to fucking kitten simulator.
Fuck the scheme, man.
I was like, it's a Roblox game.
They're not scary.
Bro, what did I play?
It's good to play a scheme because I just moved into a house
for the first time, so I'm glad I could scream.
Yeah.
Yeah, you scream.
about the echo i'm proud that this room is probably really
bad for oh yeah yeah yeah this is like your first day
streaming back too from after your move yeah yeah and we
played roblox roblox stream yeah the roblox stream
christening the new house with a big roblox stream i was so
fun though i had a great time oh yeah me too if you ever
want to play again please let me know oh my god no we should
we should totally play content warning Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm
so excited.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
We should totally do it.
That would be so fun.
You want next week?
Yeah.
Next week.
We got farm it before the game dies.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
I'm totally blind to it.
So I'll save I'll save my my innocence for Yeah, yeah, yeah,
me too.
Me too.
The only thing I know is that clip I sent
I'm sure we will discover more cursed objects.
That's fantastic.
Thank you so much.
This was so much fun Thanks for giving me the roblox tour I
was so excited I was afraid to bring you to some of the
darker ones Because I was just like how deep is this like
hole gonna go Like how should I introduce somebody who's not
seen a lot of games I think you're ready I think you're
ready to see how far this Oh yeah, yes VLAN, yeah I'll
figure out I'll get like the like Secret internet like save
of VLAN Yeah No!
Thank you again, Snuffy.
Thanks for the collab.
I'm going to go talk to my chat now, but thank you.
GG's.
Content warning next week, guys.
Next week.
Elio.
All right.
Bye-bye.
See you later.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Bye.
Oh, my God.
That was really fun.
That was actually...
I had a great...
This was my first time actually, like, collabing with
Snuffy.
We've been wanting to do a collab for like a while now Um,
like I said before at first we want to do the warrior cats
RP shit And then like, oh my god, she gone She gone Um, but
I'm really happy to be able to talk to her Like the first
hour was like literally like podcast time Oh my gosh, whoa
How do I Whoa, give me a sec
Um Um NEP Thank you for the Aka super Thank you Thank you I
really appreciate it Thank you so much Okay let me fix this
real fast Let me Let me fix the collab room Real fast chat
Okay Leave I wanna leave How do I leave?
Is this it?
Oh my gosh I'm so baby when it comes to this I think this is
good But yeah I hope you guys really enjoyed Really enjoyed
like uh stuffy on the channel um like we it was nice talking
to her for like the first hour just having a little podcast
before we even start the game and then the the scuff of us
setting up like the collab room and everything but i
definitely had a great great great great great time um thank
you everybody for watching everybody i'm going to uh do some
behind the scenes work gonna prep for my karaoke that's on
friday so i'll see you guys next time everybody i hope you
guys had a fun time say hydrated posture check it up and
move around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for
me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next
time everybody bye guys bye